bonjour à tous vous allez boire suivre
dans un instant la nouvelle lecture du
projet de loi sur les retraites en
première lecture le texte avait été
rejeté à l'unanimité au Sénas qui est
une première droite et gauche avait
votée contre car le texte avait été vidé
de sa substance par des amendements
adoptés par l'opposition alors je vous
rappelle que ce projet de loi apporté
par la ministre Marisol Touraine prévoit
l'allongement progressive de la durée de
cotisation la création d'un compte
pénibilité et le gel des pensions sur 6
mois en 2014 ce nouveau vote s'annonce
tout aussi difficile pour la majorité
car les communistes ici au Sénat
s'apprêtent à voter contre le texte ce
sera donc à l'assemblée de se prononcer
mercredi prochain voilà tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle pour la discussion
générale
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi opté
par l'Assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture garantissant l'avenir de la
justice du système de retraite dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Marisol Touraine ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs quelques mots
tout d'abord pour m'excuser de mon
retard absolument ta volontaire puisque
j'étais informé de ce que la séance
commencerait à 16h et donc j'étais tout
à fait dans les temps pour ma paire pour
qu'on vienne me dire que cette séance
avait été à une date que je ne connais
pas avancée donc je vous prie de bien
vouloir m'excuser
le projet de loi garantissant l'avenir
et la justice de notre système de
retraite revient devant vous pour un
ultime examen
les discussions ont été âpres elles ont
été longues elles ont été en tout cas
approfondie à l'occasion du 1er passage
devant votre assemblée donc je ne
reviendrai pas dans le détail sur ce qui
fait le contenu de ce texte puisque vous
le connaissez bien je voudrais
simplement insister sur la nécessité
c'est en tout cas ce qui guide le
gouvernement d'apporter une réponse en
termes de confiance vis-à-vis de notre
modèle social et ce texte de loi a pour
ambition pour volonté pour objectif de
permettre de rétablir de la confiance
vis-à-vis de notre système de retraite
en particulier chez les jeunes
générations si nous voulons que les plus
jeunes d'entre nous ne se retournent pas
vers des systèmes d'assurance privé ne
s'a vous donne pas à ne compter que sur
leur propre force et leurs propres
proches nous devons leur garantir que le
jour venu à leur tour ils pourront
également bénéficier d'une retraite de
bonne qualité et de bons niveaux et dans
un contexte économique difficile il est
donc une exigence une responsabilité un
devoir même que de fortifier notre
système de retraite les débats que nous
avons vu sont des débats qui a bien des
égards ont été intéressants et ils
correspondent à l'idée que nous pouvons
nous faire de la démocratie
parlementaire puisque vos travaux ont
permis d'éclairer le cap fixé par la
majorité ils ont permis d'ailleurs
d'enrichir le projet initial porté par
le gouvernement
le dernier examen à l'Assemblée
nationale a maintenu les grands
équilibres de la réforme mais contribuer
à compléter les textes qui avaient été
initialement prévus je voudrais être
très rapidement vous rappeler les points
principaux d'évolution depuis que nous
avons eu l'occasion de débattre de ce
texte vous rappeler d'abord que
l'allocation de solidarité aux personnes
âgées sera revalorisées deux fois au
cours de l'année 2014 non seulement au
1er avril comme c'était initialement
prévu mais également au premier octobre
date de la revalorisation générale des
pensions en 2014 ensuite le gouvernement
a fait le choix d'augmenter de 50 euros
l'aide à la complémentaire santé pour
les personnes de plus de 60 ans qui
disposent d'un revenu situé entre 715 et
cela permettra de compenser le coût de
la contribution apporter à nos régimes
de retraite je veux dire par ailleurs
que nous avons la volonté de réformer
les retraites sans entrer dans la
brutalité sans revenir à une logique de
brutalité qui pendant trop longtemps
c'est installé dans notre pays nous
avons la volonté de marquer clairement
le cap de responsabilité financière qui
est le nôtre et ce cap de responsabilité
il est tenu il est tenu à court terme à
travers des mesures de contribution qui
sont demandées à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens il est tenu à plus long
terme à travers l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation qui interviendra à
partir de 2020 mais je voudrais insister
sur le fait que c'est bien l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens qui sont appelés à
contribuer et non pas comme je l'entends
parfois
dans le débat comme je l'ai entendu ici
dans cette hémicycle sur certains bancs
et non pas certains Français
accréditants l'idée que des efforts
seraient demandés à certains cependant
que d'autres en s'arrêtent exonérés les
fonctionnaires comme les salariés sous
statut les agents sous status sont
appelés comme les autres à contribuer à
l'équilibre de nos régimes de retraite
que ce soit à travers l'augmentation de
la cotisation demandée à partir de
l'année prochaine que ce soit à travers
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
à partir de 2020 ou encore de la mise à
contribution des retraités de ces
secteurs et avec cette politique là
cette politique large et
rassemblez de notre société nous avons
la volonté de répondre de faire face aux
défis financiers qui se pose dans
l'ensemble de nos régimes de retraite
qu'il s'agisse des retraites du privé ou
des retraites du public c'est bien la
volonté la recherche de l'équilibre qui
a guidé le gouvernement mais dans le
même temps et c'est le point central de
la loi qui vous a été présenté nous
avons eu la volonté je l'ai exprimé
fermement et fortement devant vous de
tenir compte des conditions de travail
des carrières professionnelles des
conditions de vie pour déterminer les
modalités de départ en retraite ce qui
marquera à l'issue de l'adoption aussi
ce texte de loi est comme je l'espère
adopter c'est que pour la première fois
la durée de cotisation requise de la
part de nos de nos concitoyens pour
disposer d'une retraite de bonne qualité
sera moduler pour tenir compte de
critères éventuels de pénibilité de
situation
lumière comme le travail à temps partiel
ou pour les femmes les périodes de
maternité et c'est donc cette double
exigence de responsabilité financière et
de responsabilité sociale qui a été
celle du gouvernement c'est à cette
double exigence que je souhaite que nous
puissions nous appeler ensemble à
l'occasion de ce nouveau débat je
souhaite que nos travaux se poursuivent
dans un esprit de responsabilité dans le
respect de l'équilibre du texte tel
qu'il a été présenté par le gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
ne serai pas beaucoup plus longue
puisque nous avons eu l'occasion déjà
d'avoir un débat approfondie nous allons
poursuivre ce débat aujourd'hui je
souhaite que l'issue de ce débats soit
différente de celle que nous avons
connues en première lecture même si je
ne suis pas certaine d'être entendues en
tout cas le gouvernement est ici devant
vous avec le sentiment que nous ne
pouvons pas ne pas entendre l'exigence
de répondre aux préoccupations exprimées
par nos concitoyens pour ce qui est de
l'avenir de leur régime de retraite et
c'est à cette exigence là qu'ensemble
nous devons faire face avec
responsabilité merci à vous
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame Christiane de monter se
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales mes chers
collègues le projet de loi garantissant
l'avenir et la justice du système de
retraite que notre assemblée s'apprête à
nouveau à examiner en nouvelle lecture
et le fruit d'un long processus engagé
par le gouvernement il y a près de 18
mois grande conférence sociale de
juillet 2012 rapport de la commission
Moreau pour l'avenir des retraites puis
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux au début de l'été dernier la
démarche a été sérieuse et méthodique
les discussions ont été riches et
approfondie les dispositions phares du
projet de loi sont aujourd'hui bien
connus de tous il n'apparaît donc pas
utile de revenir en détail sur les
avancées proposées par le gouvernement
je souhaiterais en revanche apporter
quelques éléments de réponse aux
critiques exprimées sur les bancs de
l'opposition et de certains groupes de
la Major parlementaire contre cette
réforme
certains reprochent au gouvernement
l'insuffisance des mesures de
redressement du système de retraite et
appel de leurs vœux un changement de
paradigme à travers la mise en place
d'un régime universel par point faut-il
leur rappeler à ses collègues la
situation qui nous a été légué le besoin
de financement du système est évalué
vous le savez à 20,7 milliards d'euros
en 2020 dont 7,6 milliards d'euros pour
le régime général le fond de solidarité
vieillesse et les régimes de retraite de
base non équilibré par subvention la
réforme des retraites de 2003
envisageait pourtant un retour à
l'équilibre à l'horizon 2020 celle de
2010 l'envisageait pour 2018 les
promesses n'ont pas été tenues loin sans
faux pour faire face à cette situation
les mesures de financement prévu par le
projet de loi s'élève plus de 4
milliards d'euros en 2014 et à 8
milliards d'euros en 2020 dès l'année
prochaine le déficit des régimes de
retraite de base devrait être ramené à
1,6 milliards d'euros contre 4,1
milliards en 2013
contrairement à une idée reçue ces
mesures impliquent l'ensemble des
régimes de retraite madame la ministre
vous l'avez rappelé y compris le régime
de la fonction publique et des régimes
spéciaux ceux-ci ne seront en effet
exemptés ni de l'allongement de la durée
d'assurance ni du report de la date de
revalorisation des pensions et encore
moins de la hausse des cotisations
d'assurance vieillesse il convient en
outre mes chers collègues de tordre le
cou à deux autres affirmations
erronées je pense en premier lieu à
l'idée selon laquelle seul un changement
radical de système permettrait de mettre
un point d'arrêt au déficit
donc une réforme systémique qui
conduirait à ne modifier que
l'architecture générale de notre système
n'apporterait aucune réponse à la
nécessité de consolider le financement
de nos régimes de retraite par
répartition la commission Moro a
elle-même insisté sur ce point l'urgence
n'est pas de changer de système mais
bien de sauvegarder le financement de
nos régimes par en rééquilibrage à court
terme et en meilleur pilotage à moyen et
long terme en second lieu le taux de
remplacement assuré par les pensions
sont assez comparables entre la fonction
publique et le régime général non
déplaisent à ceux qui voudraient nous
faire croire le contraire les écarts de
niveau de pension sont en effet
entièrement imputables à un effet de
structure tant au niveau tenant au
niveau de qualification globalement plus
élevée au sein de la fonction publique
d'état je renvoie cet égard encore aux
travaux cités par la commission Moreau
ils font état d'un taux de remplacement
médian de
74,5% pour les salariés du secteur privé
et de 75,2 % pour les salariés civils du
secteur public de la génération
1942 d'autres formations politiques
estiment au contraire que la présente
réforme s'inscrit dans la continuité des
précédentes je voudrais leur rappeler
que la réforme de 2010 a bien souvent
brutalisé nos concitoyens les plus
proches de la retraite en leur imposant
sans préavis de nouvelles conditions
d'âge et en remettant en cause par la
même leur projet de fin de carrière
c'est une exigence fondamentale
sous-tend à l'inverse le présent projet
de loi demandé à tous les Français des
efforts modérés et équitablement
répartie et organiser une montée en
charge des mesures dans des conditions
d'anticipation raisonnables je pense en
particulier à l'allongement progressif
de la durée d'assurance nécessaire pour
obtenir une retraite à taux plein il
s'agit de garantir un ajustement de la
trajectoire financière sans brutalité
pour les générations proches de la
retraite je l'ai déjà dit cette mesure
est juste car elle s'accompagne de
plusieurs dispositifs visant ta
compenser ses effets pour les personnes
ayant des métiers pénibles ayant
commencé à travailler jeune ou ayant eu
des carrières heurtées le projet de loi
prend en effet en compte la situation
des assurés les plus pénalisées à
laquelle très peu de réponses avaient
été apportées jusqu'à présent pour la
première fois vous le savez ce texte
traduit par un dispositif universel le
compte personnel de prévention de la
pénibilité
le devoir qui incombe à la société de
prévenir la pénibilité et donc compenser
ses effets il marque ainsi
l'aboutissement d'un long cheminement
qui a été entamé il y a plus de 10 ans
une contribution essentielle est
également apportée à la concrétisation
de l'objectif d'égalité à travers les
mesures en faveur des femmes déjà
assurés ayant eu des carrières heurtées
des personnes handicapées de leurs
aidants familiaux ainsi que des
retraités agricoles je n'en citerai que
quelques-unes l'abaissement du seuil de
rémunération permettant de valider en
trimestre d'assurance vieillesse la mise
en place d'une aide forfaitaire du
rachat d'année d'études supérieures le
dispositif améliorant les droits à la
retraite des apprentis la création d'une
majoration de durée d'assurance pour les
aidants familiaux en charge d'un adulte
lourdement handicapé ou encore la
garantie pour les petites pensions
agricoles d'atteindre 75% du SM en 2017
plus généralement le comité de suivi des
retraites pièce maîtresse du nouveau
pays pilotage financier constituera
également un observatoire des inégalités
en matière de retraite et des moyens mis
en oeuvre pour les corrigés l'ensemble
de ces mesures marque donc assurément
une rupture avec les conceptions
précédentes avant de terminer mes chers
collègues je souhaiterais saluer la
prise en compte à l'occasion de la
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi
l'Assemblée nationale de plusieurs
revendications formulées en cours de
procédure par des élus de toutes les
sensibilités politiques plusieurs
modifications introduites dans le texte
permettent tout d'abord de faciliter la
mise en oeuvre du compte personnel de
prévention de la pénibilité le rôle que
pourra jouer la mutualité sociale
agricole la MSA dans le domaine tant de
l'information que du contrôle des
entreprises du secteur agricole et
désormais pleinement reconnu les de la
MSA pourront en effet mettre en oeuvre
l'information des salariés dans le cadre
d'une convention tripartite avec l'État
et la Caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse la CNAV ils pourront
également contrôler l'effectivité de
l'exposition facteurs de pénibilité sans
que leur soit nécessaire d'être saisis
qui leur soit nécessaire d'être saisi
d'une demande en ce sens par le
gestionnaire du compte
l'Assemblée nationale a en outre prévu
comme je l'avais suggéré une périodicité
de 5 ans pour la réalisation du rapport
du Gouvernement sur l'évaluation et
l'évolution des conditions de pénibilité
auxquelles sont exposées les salariés et
sur la mise en oeuvre des dispositifs de
prévention créés par le projet de loi ce
suivi périodique me paraît fondamental
pour tenir compte des mutations rapides
du monde du travail l'adaptation à ces
nouvelles formes d'organisation
nécessite une grande réactivité pour
connaître les effets et une réflexion
approfondie pour prévenir les nouvelles
formes de pénibilité enfin les
partenaires sociaux des branches
professionnelles sont désormais mieux
associés aux comptes à travers en accord
de branche étendu il pourront aider les
entreprises à assurer la traçabilité des
expositions professionnelles dans la
fiche de prévention des expositions et à
identifier les salariés éligibles aux
comptes personnel de prévention de la
pénibilité en ce qui concerne le cumul
emploi retraite plusieurs d'entre vous
avaient insisté en première lecture sur
les difficultés engendrées par
l'existence de régime complémentaire
dans lesquels les pensions ne peuvent
être liquidées qu'à un âge supérieur à
l'âge légal c'est par exemple le cas
dans la plupart des régimes de retraite
complémentaire des professions libérales
le projet de loi dispose désormais que
les assurés n'auront pas
obligation de liquider l'ensemble de
leurs pensions de retraite pour pouvoir
continuer leur activité dans le cadre du
cumul emploi retraite des plafonné cette
solution nous semble être un bon
compromis entre la nécessité
d'harmoniser les dispositions du cumul
emploi retraite dans le sens d'une plus
grande équité entre les salariés et les
assurés pardon et celle de ne pas
pénaliser les personnes dans la retraite
complémentaire ne peut être liquidée
qu'à un âge supérieur à l'âge légal
deux modifications introduites par
l'Assemblée nationale font enfin écho
aux amendements que vous aviez accepté
dans le domaine de la gouvernance du
système de retraite d'une part c'est au
sein du Conseil commun de la fonction
publique que se déroulera le débat
annuel sur la politique des retraites
dans la fonction publique dans les trois
fonctions publiques d'ailleurs nous
évitons ainsi la création d'une nouvelle
instance de concertation et garantissons
donc la représentation effective des
fonctions publiques d'État territoriales
et hospitalières d'autre part en ce qui
concerne les régimes de retraite des
professions libérales les conditions de
nomination du directeur de la Caisse
nationale sont assouplis par la
suppression de la limite de temps prévu
pour cette fonction le texte prévoit
dorénavant que le mandat du directeur
est de 5 ans renouvelable la demande
émanant de la caisse elle-même est
relayée par plusieurs d'entre nous est
ainsi satisfaite
s'agissant pour terminer des mesures de
financement la prise en compte de la
situation des bénéficiaires de la
location de solidarité aux personnes
âgées est améliorées comme vous l'avez
rappelé à l'instant madame la ministre
le gouvernement en effet entendu les
préoccupations soulevées par plusieurs
d'entre nous et prévu une double
revalorisation du minimum vieillesse en
2014 monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la
Commission des social à adopter le 4
décembre dernier le projet de loi
garantissant l'avenir et la justice du
système de retraite dans la rédaction
issue des travaux de l'Assemblée
nationale en nouvelle lecture malgré ce
vote positif le rejet du texte en
première lecture et l'échec de la
commission mixte de paritaire laisse peu
d'espoir sur les suppositifs de nos
débats je le déplore évidemment car
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le souligner
maintenant à de nombreuses reprises ce
texte ados a un effort de redressement
indéniable de nombreuses mesures
d'équité qui permettent de prendre en
compte la diversité des situations
sociales et professionnelles face à la
retraite
l'exigence de justice est en effet au
cœur du projet qui nous est proposé
comme elle l'a été depuis l'entrée en
fonction du gouvernement dois-je
rappeler que l'une des toutes premières
munissures prises par celui-ci a été
avec le décret du 2 juillet 2012
d'élargir le dispositif de retraite
anticipée pour carrière longue aux
assurés ayant commencé à travailler
avant l'âge de 20 ans après son passage
à l'Assemblée nationale le texte sur
lequel nous devons nous prononcer à
gagner tant en précision qu'en cohérence
en engageant au-delà des mesures de
redressement et d'équité un nouvel acte
du droit à l'information en matière de
retraite il réunit donc les conditions
d'une plus grande confiance dans la
faculté des régimes de retraite à
remplir leurs objectifs non seulement
financiers mais aussi sociaux je le dis
le Sénat sonorerait en lui réservant une
suite favorable je vous remercie
merci madame le rapporteur dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à Madame Laurence Cohen pour le groupe
CRC
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues alors que nous nous
apprêtons à débuter l'examen en seconde
lecture de ce projet de loi portant
réforme des retraites vous ne serez pas
surpris qu'au nom du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen je réitère comme
nous l'avons dit on fait en première
lecture notre opposition et pourtant
comme vous madame la ministre nous
sommes conscients que la situation
actuelle des comptes sociaux et
singulièrement ceux de la caisse de
retraite nationale d'assurance
vieillesse connaissent des difficultés
économiques auxquelles il convient
d'apporter des réponses d'urgentes
urgentes et durable pour assurer
l'avenir des retraites par répartition à
laquelle nos concitoyens sont attachés
mais aussi pour restaurer la confiance
de ces derniers à l'égard de nos régimes
de retraite nous le savons toutes et
tous de plus en plus de nos concitoyens
redoutent de ne plus pouvoir compter à
l'avenir sur les retraites servies par
le régime général de base comme par les
organismes complémentaires pour vivre
dignement une fois l'âge la retraite
atteint cette crainte je veux le dire
ici est alimenté par plus de 10 ans de
réforme qui se sont toutes traduites par
des reculs et des renoncements qu'il
s'agisse de l'indexation des retraites
sur les prix plutôt que sur les salaires
des modalités de calcul des pensions des
conditions de revalorisation des
modifications de bornes d'âge ou de
multiples allongements de la durée de
cotisation tout a été jusqu'à
aujourd'hui générateur d'angoisse autant
que d'injustice la réforme de 2010 par
exemple parce qu'elle a allongé la durée
de cotisation a eu pour effet majeur de
repousser l'âge réel de départ à la
retraite et d'entraîner des décodes de
l'ordre de 8% dans le secteur privé et
15% dans le secteur public
la matière d'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes mais nous n'avons
pas été entendus nous avons proposé en
vain aussi de réduire progressivement
ces mêmes exonérations sur les basses
salaires qui incitent les employeurs à
précariser l'emploi et à sous rémunérer
les salariés en 20 encore nous avons
proposé de moduler les cotisations
sociales de telle sorte que celle-ci
soit moins importante pour les
entreprises qui favorisent l'emploi et
les salaires et plus lourdes sur celles
qui délocalisent et préfèrent nourrir la
bulle spéculative et les actionnaires
plutôt que les salariés et l'économie
réelle on va enfin nous avons proposé
d'instaurer une cotisation sociale sur
les revenus financiers vous ne pouvez
pas dire madame la ministre que le
groupe CRC n'a pas proposé de solutions
alternatives à votre projet en lieu et
place ce que nous proposions vous avez
pour votre part préférez allonger la
durée de cotisation je l'ai les pensions
des retraités modestes pendant 9 mois et
privé les salariés en situation de
handicap titulaire d'une RQTH de des
rares mesures positives que ce projet de
loi contenait de la même manière la
prise en compte de la pénibilité si elle
diffère de ce que la droite avait fait
auparavant c'est-à-dire une constatation
médicale des dégâts causés par le
travail n'est toujours pas la mesure
juste et préventive que nous appelons de
nos vœux en cas d'exposition multiple
seul deux facteurs seront prises en
compte afin de réduire la portée et le
coût du dispositif de la même manière
vous instaurez des seuils alors même que
les juristes prudence en cas de maladie
professionnelle tant à rappeler que
cette notion de seuil n'est pas des plus
pertinente enfin l'amendement que nous
avions déposé et que le Sénat avait
adopté prévoyant une priorité de
reclassement pour les salariés
bénéficiants d'une formation
professionnelle au titre de la prise en
compte de la pénibilité n'a pas été
retenu par l'Assemblée
tout cela nous conduit donc et pas de
gaieté de coeur comme nous l'avions fait
en première lecture à voter contre ce
projet de loi qui pour l'essentiel de
notre point de vue et par rapport aux
éléments que j'ai rapidement développé
n'auront pas fondamentalement avec les
contre-réformes précédentes et ne
correspond aucunement aux ambitions que
vous affichez je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur Robert
troppellano pour le groupe RDS
monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues
les réformes engagées ces 20 dernières
années n'ont pas permis de rétablir
l'équilibre général de notre système de
retraite les défait le déficit sera de
plus de 20 milliards en 2020 la crise
économique de ces dernières années et la
religion de l'espérance de vie nous
exhorte à prendre des mesures notre
collègue Françoise Laborde l'a rappelé
en première lecture nous devons à la
fois permettre aux actifs qui arrivent
en fin de carrière de pouvoir partir à
la retraite dans de bonnes conditions et
assurer aux générations futures qu'elles
pourront bénéficier d'une retraite
convenable il en est de notre
responsabilité vous l'avez souligné
madame la ministre
dans son rapport de janvier dernier le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
s'est interrogé sur l'opportunité de
maintenir de nombreux régimes aux règles
différentes et nous incitent à
simplifier un système de retraite
particulièrement complexe
c'est pourquoi nous plaidons pour la
mise en place d'une réforme systémique
dans un souci de consolider notre
système par répartition sur ce point je
sais que nous divergeons madame la
ministre pour autant vous avez fait le
choix d'une réforme globale responsable
et juste vis-à-vis notamment des femmes
avec la validation des périodes de congé
maternité des jeunes avec la
valorisation des années d'apprentissage
et de stage mais aussi vis-à-vis des
retraités agricoles des personnes
handicapées et des carrières heurtées je
pense enfin et surtout à la mise en
place du compte personnel de prévention
de la pénibilité mesure phare de votre
réforme nous le savons bien malgré les
progrès des technologies et
l'automatisation de certaines
professions les cas entre l'espérance de
vie de cadres des cadres et celles des
ouvriers ne disparaît pas d'après
l'Insee les hommes cadres de 35 ans
peuvent espérer vivre encore 47 ans
contre 41 ans pour les ouvriers dans ces
conditions permettre à des salariés dans
l'activité professionnelle réduit leur
espérance de vie constituée
incontestablement une avancée majeure
contrairement à la réforme de 2010 qui
avait fait le choix d'indemniser
l'indemnité votre texte madame la
ministre rapporte de vrais solutions aux
problèmes de pénibilité au travail je
regrette d'ailleurs qu'en première
lecture notre assemblée rejeté cet
article particulièrement important
certes tant à l'Assemblée nationale
cosséna dévoile se sont élevés pour
dénoncer un dispositif complexe oui sa
mise en oeuvre soulèvera peut-être
quelques difficultés je tiens toutefois
à rappeler qu'il est prévu d'associer
davantage les partenaires sociaux par
ailleurs Michel Sapin et vous-même
madame la ministre avait confié à Michel
de Virville une mission de facilitation
de concertation permanente sur la mise
en oeuvre opérationnelle du compte
personnel de prévention de la pénibilité
il est en effet important que ce compte
puisse se mettre en place dans des
conditions de simplicité maximale et de
sécurité juridique tant pour les
salariés que pour les entreprises quoi
qu'il en soit cette mesure constitue une
grande avancée sociale pour tous ceux
qui travaillent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles
d'autres améliorations ont été apportées
au texte par l'Assemblée nationale nous
ne pouvons que nous en réjouir d'autant
plus que certaines l'ont été à
l'initiative du groupe rrdp je pense
bien sûr au rôle joué par la Mutualité
sociale agricole dans la mise en œuvre
du compte personnel de prévention de la
pénibilité
s'agissant du cumul emploie retraite le
projet de loi précise désormais que les
salariés n'ont pas l'obligation de
liquider leur pension de retraite pour
pouvoir continuer leur activité dans le
cadre du cumul emploi retraite dit des
plafonnés c'est une très bonne chose je
m'affiche félicite également que les
députés faisant écho à des amendements
déposés par notre collègue Gilbert
Barbier et rappelait que la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse des
professionnels libérales doivent assurer
la cohésion et la coordination des
systèmes d'information et qu'ils aient
sensiblement assoupli des conditions de
nomination du directeur
je dirais enfin un mot sur le report de
la revalorisation des pensions du
premier au premier avril et au 1er
octobre en première lecture le rdrdse et
plusieurs autres groupes avaient choisi
de supprimer l'article 4 il s'agissait
avant tout de préserver les petites
pensions d'épargner des retraités les
plus modestes ceux qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté notre devoir est de
venir en aide au plus défavorisé mais
aussi d'améliorer la situation des
retraités les plus vulnérables depuis le
premier ministre a pris des engagements
en premier lieu la location de
solidarité aux personnes âgées sera
revalorisée à deux reprises l'année
prochaine le 1er avril et le 1er octobre
ensuite alors que certains suspensionnés
ne se soignent plus comme il faut par
manque de moyens financiers vous avez
augmenté de 10% l'aide à la
complémentaire santé pour la porter à
550 euros
notre groupe se félicite que le
gouvernement ait été sensible aux
préoccupations que nous avons soulevé à
maintes reprises s'agissant des
retraités les plus modestes pour autant
cet article 4 va pénaliser les retraités
qui ne bénéficient pas dans la location
de solidarité aux personnes âgées mais
qui pourtant vivent dans la précarité
bien entendu madame la ministre comme un
premier lecture nous proposerons
quelques amendements pour améliorer ce
texte toujours dans un souci d'une plus
grande justice sociale et de plus grande
respect des principes de responsabilité
et d'équité
merci la parole est à Monsieur Jean des
Essarts pour le groupe écologique
voilà donc monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre
madame la rapporteur chers collègues
nous voilà seconde lecture ce texte
et
je ne sais pas comment nous devons
interpréter le résultat de la première
lecture
enfin mis à part qu'on a battu à record
mais à triste record
0 voix pour
un projet de loi
uneanimité contre uneanimité contre
oui enfin
c'est pas moi qui je suis d'accord c'est
grotesque chers collègues
alors sans doute vous allez expliquer ce
réseau
ouais mais enfin ça montre bien quand
même les difficultés de concertation que
nous avons Sénat ou alors les rapports
du Sénat avec l'Assemblée mais enfin
pour arriver alors on pourrait dire que
on nous en parlons pas parce que c'est
une mauvaise situation
malgré tout je considère que ça illustre
la difficulté de travail en amont sur
les textes alors encore le dit à la
tribune comme ça on nous dit bon voilà
les parlementaires sont pas contents et
bien sûr la fois prochaine on va vous
associer bien les maisons alors que ça
soit quand c'est la droite il nous le
disparaît et quand c'est la gauche
pareil et je suis sûr que s'il y avait
le centre hop peut-être qu'à l'heure on
va vous laisser le bénéfice du doute bon
et à nous aussi écologiste mais on a on
arrive quand même aux limites du travail
de préparation
et en ce qui concerne les écologistes on
l'a toujours dit et après faut pas
s'étonner dans votre compte que nous
sommes opposés à l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation c'est une donnée de
base pour nous écologistes alors soit
vous construisez avec d'autres forces
politiques pour avoir une issu positive
à l'issue d'un débat au Sénat soit vous
considérez bah voilà on jette dans le
vide et puis on va bien voir s'il y a un
parachute qui nous rattrape
nous sommes opposés à l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation vous pouvez dire
mon chers collègues que c'est grotes
c'est nos idées fondamentales alors
peut-être que c'était grotesque une
alliance gouvernementale ensemble mais
quand vous faites un partenariat avec
une force politique
considérons considérons malgré tout
qu'elle a quelques options fondamentales
et que lorsqu'on fait un texte en entier
compte ou alors on dit sur ce point-là
il y a une vraie divergence et on va
travailler avec d'autres mais là ce
qu'on travaille un texte dans une
majorité gouvernementale et
présidentielle on tient compte des idées
fondamentales des partenaires et pour
nous écologistes le fait de partage du
travail est justement le non allongement
des cotisations et quelque chose de
fondamental c'est fondamental parce que
comment expliquer un jeune aujourd'hui
qui va devoir travailler 67 ans qui a
fait des études alors que les aînés
pouvaient se retirer du marché du
travail à 62 ans alors que la
productivité des entreprises progresse
c'est inadapté comment expliquer que les
seigneurs qui trouvent pas du travail à
55 60 ans vont en trouver à 62 63
comment expliquer que les seigneurs qui
trouvent que les jeunes qui trouvent pas
de travail les anciens vont pouvoir en
trouver et que si les anciens
travaillent plus longtemps les jeunes
vont travailler davantage comment
voulez-vous expliquer cela à la société
aujourd'hui et puis ça justifier parce
que le problème n'est pas l'espérance de
vie mais principalement les effets du
papy boom alors sur l'article 4 donc
vous avez compris
nous sommes très opposés à l'article 2
sur l'article 4 nous saluons les
déclarations de Premier ministre qui a
donné des signes de bonne volonté en
annonçant un double revalorisation de la
SPA en 2014 et une majorité majoration
de l'aide à l'acquisition du
complémentaire santé pour compenser les
mesures contenues dans cet article
cependant sur le pont de l'article qui
instaure un décalage de six mois de
revalorisation des pensions de retraite
hors minimum vieillesse notre opposition
reste inchangée nous sommes conscients
que ce report devrait rapporter près de
1 milliard d'euros par an jusqu'en 2020
mais malheureusement cet effort demandé
madame la ministre vous l'avez dit il
est demandé à tous mais quand on demande
50 euros à tous ou une très faible
progressivité c'est davantage pour ceux
qui a un vrai procuron un vrai problème
de pouvoir d'achat que pour ceux qui
sont plus aisés ou qui ont davantage les
moyens
à nous ne pensons pas qu'une personne
retraité qui touche un peu plus de
787,26 787
euro 26 centimes par mois puis cette
considéré comme suffisamment aisé pour
supporter un décalage de six mois en
matière de revalorisation de sa pension
de retraite et ce malgré les mesures
avancées par le Premier ministre nous
proposerons donc encore une fois la
suppression de cet article
alors évidemment une fois que tout cela
est dû on peut noter quand même qu'il y
a quelques articles intéressants en
particulier les articles 5 et 6 qui
permettent de réellement prendre en
compte la pénibilité
viennent ensuite les différentes mesures
pour les carrières heurtées l'extension
de la retraite progressive et la
possibilité de donner aux assurés de
valider un trimestre avec des
cotisations sur 150 heures au lieu de
200 aujourd'hui et enfin nous nous
félicitons que le gouvernement est
inscrit la prise en compte des
trimestres d'apprentissage pour la
retraite dans son projet de loi et qu'il
soit prévu une simplification du système
de versement des pensions et un
renforcement du droit à l'information
qui apporte un peu de clarté dans notre
système si complexe
et donc je ne serai je ne sais pas quel
sera le résultat final
suite à nos débats
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui à ce moment
même les élus écologistes du Sénat
opposé à l'augmentation de la durée des
cotisations ne pourront voter ce texte
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Noël Cardou pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le Président Madame le Ministre
et chers collègues je vais m'engouffrer
dans la porte que m'a ouverte notre
collègue Jean des c'est ça et j'aurais
tendance à dire que cette seconde
lecture du texte sur la réforme des
retraites je l'intitulée monsieur Vergoz
vous parlez à la fin vous parlez à la
fin on laisse parler l'orateur s'il vous
plaît donc où comment faire oublier un
vote inédit dans l'histoire de la Haute
Assemblée 346 à 0 malgré une tentative
de passage en force par un vote bloqué
sur le texte de l'Assemblée nationale
alors comment essayer de le faire
oublier il y a deux étapes la première
étape quelques tentatives de replatrages
auxquelles nous commençons à nous
habituer je les énumérerai très
sommairement rôle de la MSA pour la mise
en oeuvre du compte pénibilité
périodicité de 5 ans pour le rapport du
gouvernement sur la pénibilité débat
annuel sur les retraites au sein de la
fonction publique suppression de la
limite de temps pour la nomination du
directeur de la scène VPN non
application du report de revalorisation
bénéficiaires du minimum vieillesse que
Monsieur de César a souligné et
assouplissement du cumul emploi retraite
voilà ce que l'on nous propose comme
modification par rapport au texte
initial je dis c'est tout et c'est bien
peu deuxième étape pour faire oublier ce
vote c'est aussi assez inédit quand
commission l'ordre du jour de la
commission des affaires sociales a été
inversée sans en avertir ou tout au
moins au dernier moment les commissaires
si bien que le rapport de la rapporteuse
a été adoptée un peu à la hussarde avec
un minimum de voix alors que tous les
sénateurs n'étaient pas arrivés c'est
une manœuvre de procédure qui a permis
d'afficher après que la Commission avait
adopté le rapport alors qu'en fait il
n'y avait pas de majorité réelle dans la
commission pour adopter ce rapport alors
ces subterfuge ne change rien au fond
c'est très fort mais en fait une non
réforme une tentative de colmatage qui
ne résout pas les problèmes financiers
des régimes de retraite la gauche n'a
jamais entrepris une seule réforme des
retraites et le gouvernement le confirme
malheureusement aujourd'hui avec ce
texte alors numéro un certain nombre de
critiques de fonds un peu suivant un
inventaire non respect de la
loi-coraleuse de 2010 de la loi Fillon
qui avait prévu une réforme systémique
en 2013 donc nous y sommes abandonnés et
en soulignant cette loi Fillon a permis
aussi d'économiser 4 milliards quatre
d'euros entre 2012 et 2016 une fuite en
avant financière puisque les déficits
des régimes de base devrait atteindre 13
milliards d'euros en 2020 et que les
mesures proposées au mieux des gazerons
7 milliards d'euros et quand je dis au
mieux c'est parce que ça a été projeté
suivant une évolution de la croissance
de 1,6 par an nous en sommes loin
actuellement et je pense que
de augmentation de la croissance est un
veuf pieux donc en fait le gouvernement
ne fait que repousser à plus tard les
vrais enjeux dans l'espoir d'un
miraculeux redressement économique mais
je pense pas que la politique générale
qu'il mette en œuvre aille dans ce sens
aucune mesure allant dans le sens de la
convergence du public et du privé aucune
volonté de réfléchir sur un système de
capitalisation dont on sait bien que tôt
ou tard il verra le jour et pas très
fort ni de mutualisation dans les
méthodes de gestion dans le coût dans le
coup 6 milliards d'euros et deux fois
plus élevé que les autres pays européens
Espagne Italie ou Allemagne le potentiel
d'économie sur la gestion des caisses de
retraite serait de l'ordre de 2 et demi
à 3 milliards d'euros et au contraire on
s'engouffe dans une énième structure en
créant un comité de suivi des retraites
composées de normes nommés par décret il
faut pas que cela échappe que ce soit
il ne pourra pas partir à la retraite au
taux plein qu'à partir de 66 ans c'est
donc une
augmentation déguisée de l'âge de départ
à la retraite et en fait
même si on maintient à 60 même si l'âge
de d'écart est maintenu à 62 ans
mécaniquement pour avoir des retraites à
taux plein nous arrivons à 66 ans et
dans le même temps il faut signaler que
le Royaume-Uni qui arrive en tête des
performances économiques des pays
occidentaux avec un recul du chômage
important 400 000 emplois créés un
rebond significatif de la croissance du
5,4 cette année et bien ce même
gouvernement envisage de repousser à 68
ans puis à 69 à l'horizon 2040 là je le
départ à la retraite
autre problème tentative d'appréhender
les réserves des caisses et professions
libérales avec un directeur nommé par
l'État ce couvert d'un rapport de Ligas
avançant une gestion hasardeuse moi je
viens gestion hasardeuse à 15 milliards
d'excédents
j'aimerais bien que toutes les gestions
soient aussi hasardeuses bon c'est sûr
que quand on veut tuer son chien on dit
qu'il a la rage je remarque simplement
que la critique de du rapport de Lyca ça
même mis en cause
l'opportunité de certains placements des
caisses de retraite jusqu'à maintenant
on voit le résultat dans les excédents
et enfin dernière chose refus
catégorique d'envisager une retraite par
coin pour le régime de base alors que
les partenaires sociaux patronaux et
même syndicaux pour certains s'ils sont
montrés favorables avec la perspective
d'apporter des additions pour résoudre
ce fameux problème de la pénibilité
il est clair que c'est une numération
incomplète mais qui a fléché des
principaux sujets confirment que cette
réforme n'est pas une réforme mais un
ajustement financier et lorsqu'on ajuste
financièrement et bien la grande
spécialité du gouvernement là comme
ailleurs
est taxé
depuis plusieurs mois on ne connaît que
ça on crée des impôts on crée des
charges nouvelles et à partir du moment
où on se relance dans un épisode de
taxation et bien on va freiner la
compétitivité des entreprises et réduire
le pouvoir d'achat alors on va faire
encore une autre petite liste petite
liste de des conséquences de cette
ajustement financier et le premier a
déjà été souligné une augmentation de
0,3% des cotisations des actifs en 2013
pour financer le retour de la retraite à
60 ans
de plus avec la fiscalisation des bonus
pour trois enfants il existe un risque
sérieux de faire basculer dans l'impôt
sur le revenu un nombre important de
retraités et comme toujours c'est les
classes moyennes qui indirectement
seront pénalisés par ces ajustements
financiers des plafonnement des
cotisations des travailleurs
indépendants en milliards d'euros qui
viennent se superposer au déplafonnement
que ces mêmes travailleurs indépendants
avec connus l'année dernière en matière
d'assurance maladie financement de la
majoration des retraites des exploitants
agricoles par les agriculteurs eux-mêmes
et non par la solidarité nationale comme
l'avait promis le président de la
République au moment de sa campagne
report de six mois de la révision des
pensions de retraite ce qui va toucher
de plein fouet une fois de plus les
classes moyennes alors que dans le même
temps le gouvernement le gouvernement
refuse l'amendement belle Debré sur le
complément de revenus pour les
bénéficiaires du minimum vieillesse
prétendant intervenir par voie
réglementaire au mépris du travail et de
la légitimité du département j'ajoute
que cette mesure qui avait été adoptée à
la casino
si elle avait été mise en oeuvre en
temps normal c'est à dire en janvier de
cette année et bien ce sont des milliers
de personnes qui ont des revenus faibles
qui auraient pu bénéficier d'un
complément de revenus et qu'on laisse au
bord de la route alors que tout était là
pour leur donner satisfaction et puis
enfin et surtout la mise en place de
l'usine à gaz du comte de pénibilité
dans le coût est estimé à 2 milliards et
demi d'euros en 2040 les financer
uniquement à hauteur de 800 millions
d'euros et dont on sait bien que le
résultat principal sera d'anticiper
l'âge de départ au détriment de la
formation et de la prévention tous les
contacts que nous avons pu avoir avec
les organisations d'employeurs nous ont
dit que dans ce compte de pénibilité la
seule chose qu'on des salariés concernés
c'est que finalement pourra partir plus
tôt et ne font pas du tout cas des
possibilités de formation et de
prévention donc ce coût administratif
est financier de cette conte de
pénibilité va rapidement se révéler
insupportable pour les TP déjà prise à
la gorge et je crains je crains que dans
l'année à venir au contraire de propos
l'émission qui nous sont assénés à
longueur de journée nous ayons une
multitude de dépôts de bilan et dépôt de
bilan de petites entreprises qui ne
peuvent plus y arriver et je pense que
ajouter encore ce compte pénibilité qui
de plus va générer des frais
administratifs en honoraire de conseils
pour arriver à le gérer et quelque chose
qui va une fois de plus freiner la
compétitivité des entreprises alors je
vais m'arrêter là on pourrait continuer
encore sur un certain nombre de
problèmes je pense simplement que j'ai
énuméré les principaux griefs et les
principaux critiques que notre groupe
formule à l'égard de cette réforme est
de cette ajustement financier comme je
l'ai appelé à plusieurs reprises et bien
entendu nous avons représenté une
quinzaine d'amendements et qui sont tous
la conséquence de ce que je viens
d'énumérer alors guise de conclusion
j'aurais tendance à dire
comment ne pas faire le parallèle en ce
texte d'ajustement financier et les
grandes envolées du Premier ministre
affichant il y a peu de temps une remise
à plat fiscal donc personne ne sait où
elle commence ni surtout quand elle
s'achèvera d'autant qu'il vient lui-même
d'annoncer que une telle réforme prendra
au moins de quinquennat et encore ce
matin j'ai entendu un élément réminant
du gouvernement actuel dire oh ben non
finalement
c'est pas si urgent que ça la principale
mesure à prendre et là je ne peux qu'à
trouver dès demain et de faire des
économies réelles mais pas des économies
réelles c'est-à-dire taillées dans les
dépenses et non pas simplement ralentir
le rythme d'évolution des dépenses comme
cela se passe actuellement on a affaire
une mystification à ce niveau là on est
en train de nous dire on réduit les
dépenses c'est pas vrai on fait en sorte
que les dépenses
progresse moins vite la véritable
réalité dont on aurait besoin dans ce
pays financièrement c'est de tailler
dans les dépenses et je pense pas que la
remise à plat fiscal dont nous a parlé
le Premier ministre et soit de nature
aller dans ce sens-là alors en revanche
voilà pourquoi j'ai fait ce parallèle
avec cette réforme fiscale et bien pour
les retraites toutes les clés étaient là
va faire référence une fois de plus à la
boîte à outils mais les rapports les
multiples rapports le corps les
partenaires sociaux se sont prononcés il
y avait des études la précédente
majorité avait travaillé il suffisait de
puiser dans ce dans ces éléments dans
ces rapports pour pouvoir présenter une
réforme systémique une réforme de fond
qui répondrait réellement aux besoins en
matière de retraite de nos pays qui
soient de nature
se rediriger vers un équilibre financier
mais alors là c'était trop simple
c'était trop simple et donc le
gouvernement n'a pas fait tout
simplement parce que là il produit plus
d'affichage mais il s'agit simplement de
faire preuve de courage politique alors
pour conclure et bien je dirais que
cette méthode de gouvernement
n'est pas la nôtre et que pour la
seconde fois et d'ailleurs je crois que
des précédents orateurs Madame le
Ministre et madame le rapporteur et on
fait allusion pour la seconde fois nous
voterons contre ce texte dont je doute
une fois de plus qu'il fasse la peur de
la Haute Assemblée mais même si les
arguments qu'on les groupes politiques
du Sénat sont souvent divergents sur le
fond je pense que nous entendons au
moins sur la forme et que c'est pas une
façon de traiter de la Haute Assemblée
comme l'a dit notre collègue tout à
l'heure décesseurs de procéder ainsi
merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Marie Vandenberghe pour le groupe
udi
UC
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
n'étaient les quelques modifications
marginales qui ont été apportées à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le même
texte c'est le même projet qui a été
rejeté à l'unanimité ici même par le
Sénat dont nous sommes aujourd'hui
saisis
le texte du Gouvernement en effet et
bien le même que celui contre lequel
nous nous sommes déjà très clairement
prononcé le 5 novembre dernier
et ce vote à l'unanimité de ce vote
plutôt à l'unanimité du Sénat vous ne
tirez aucune conclusion madame la
ministre pourtant un tel vote n'est pas
anodin
vous pensez
l'unanimité je n'ai jamais vu ça ici au
Sénat sur un vote
et ce sens vous le connaissez madame la
ministre la présente très fort nous
apparaît mal ficelé
elle répond certes relatifs consensus
syndical mais ce consensus ne se
retrouve aucunement au sein de la
représentation nationale ici au Sénat
mais de cela vous faites fille
et ben je trouve que c'est un grave
manquement à la démocratie parlementaire
vous dans ces conditions la nouvelle
lecture aujourd'hui ne peut apparaître
comme un pur artifice
pourtant il me semble qu'un autre
scénario était possible
vous auriez pu écouter les propositions
que nous vous avons faites et qui ne
remettent en rien en cause le modèle
social notre modèle social il n'y a pas
eu ici d'opposition idéologique
nous avons voulu être constructif
selon nous vous le savez la logique des
réformes paramétriques assorties des
clauses de revoyure a atteint ses
limites
seul une réforme systémique peut
vraiment garantir l'avenir et la justice
du système des retraites contrairement
à ce que vous venez de dire Madame la
rapporteur c'était d'ailleurs votre
position
en 2010 dans le rapport de la Mecque que
vous avez consignée
l'avenir parce que le remplacement de la
nuitée par le point permettrait de
revenir de remettre à plat le système
pour faire converger tous les tous les
régimes en un régime unique
c'est ça l'avenir ce qui rendrait le
système enfin lisible et transparent et
en faciliterait considérablement le
pilotage
c'est aussi la justice que ce système
permettrait ce système de retraite
permettrait de
d'atteindre parce qu'aujourd'hui il est
parfaitement inéquitable aujourd'hui
deux assurés peuvent avoir deux
carrières parfaitement comparables et se
retrouver avec des droits à la retraite
allant du simple double uniquement parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le même statut
la multiplicité des régimes aux règles
différentes ne se justifie plus et
génère des injustices qui ne sont plus
acceptées
seul donc une remise à plat transparente
de ce système permettrait différencier
les situations des assurés sur des
critères objectifs par exemple pour
uniformiser les avantages familiaux et
surtout pour prendre en compte la
pénibilité
il faut bien se souvenir que c'est au
départ la raison d'être des régimes
spéciaux mais depuis leur création la
pénibilité a considérablement évolué le
système doit donc évoluer en conséquence
et mieux protéger ceux qui sont exposés
à de réelles facteurs de pénibilité
c'est ce que permettrait un régime
unique
comment s'effectuerait la transition et
bien comme elle sait déjà effectuée dans
des pays tels que la Suède l'Italie ou
la Pologne
elle serait progressive bien sûr au
moins 10 ans dans son septième rapport
du 27 janvier 2010 le corps a très bien
étudié les scénarios de mise en œuvre
d'une telle réforme elle devrait être
précédée d'un véritable débat national
c'est tout ce que prévoit l'amendement
que nous avons fait adopter en première
lecture ici et que nous redéposerons
aujourd'hui une réforme systémique qui
correspond aux attentes de nos
concitoyens qui sont des en septembre
dernier par l'Institut louis-ary se sont
prononcés à 73%
en faveur de cette convergence des
régimes du public du privé et des
régimes spéciaux pour les fondre dans un
régime unique une idée qui fait son
chemin puisque la majorité des syndicats
pour et qui s'y même sur les bancs de
cette hémicycle nous avons des collègues
du RDSE ils viennent de se prononcer en
cette faveur en la faveur du régime
unique ou de l'UMP jusqu'à vous-même
madame la rapporteur je l'ai rappelé
mais le gouvernement y est fermé à
double tour de même qu'au débat public
qui en vertu de la réforme de 2010
devait être organisé
au premier semestre 2013 et il n'a
jamais eu lieu elle gouvernement a même
prétendu que ce débat c'était le rapport
Moreau de qui se moque-t-on cette
fermeture nous ne pouvons que la
déplorer la présenterai forme est
totalement verrouillée en témoigne ce
qui s'est passé sur l'article 4 du texte
depuis le début de la navette qui décale
de six mois la date de revalorisation
des pensions de retraite
à chacun de ces passages
devant l'Assemblée nationale comme ici
l'article 4 a été supprimé à chacun de
ces passages devant l'une ou l'autre
assemblée le gouvernement la rétablit en
seconde délibération assortie d'un vote
bloqué
c'est encore ce qui s'est produit à
l'Assemblée nationale dans la nouvelle
lecture alors même que les députés de la
majorité gouvernementale avaient déposé
des amendements du compromis visant à
exonéré
de la mesure les pensions inférieures à
1028 euros par mois le gouvernement a
tout refusé au motif principal que la
SPA la location de solidarité aux
personnes âgées qui anciens minimum
vieillesse serait doublement revalorisé
en 2014 mais ce à l'heure que les
bénéficiaires de la SPA ne sont pas
concernés par l'article 4 encore une
fois de qui se moque-t-on en conclusion
puisque rien ne doit changer et bien ne
vote notre vote ne changera pas non
merci la parole est à Monsieur Michel
Vergoz pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
mes collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
dire que
laisser croire que ce texte est si
mauvais
que les socialistes même en premier
lecture l'ont rejeté
je dis mes collègues
vendre lenberg et de ce soir c'est
grotesque
parce que ces grotesques et d'une
mauvaise foi qui confine
à l'intox
voir à la désinformation
je voudrais simplement préciser ici que
j'ai voté contre ce texte en premier
lecture parce que vous l'aviez non pas
seulement dénaturé monsieur des Essarts
vous l'aviez totalement changé et
bouleversé je pense qu'il était
important qu'on remette les choses dans
leur juste ordre
après une deuxième lecture constructive
à l'Assemblée nationale le texte que
représente le projet de loi garantissant
l'avenir et la justice du système de
retraite nous revient aujourd'hui au
Sénat je tiens ainsi à commencer mon
propos par
l'ambition qui doit tous nous animer
aujourd'hui
celle de dépasser les postures
pour réellement faire évoluer notre
système de retraite dans le bon sens
les riches débattes nous avons entre
tenus dans nos deux assemblées en
première lecture ont montré l'intérêt
que tous les parlementaires dans leur
diversité emportée à ce sujet
cependant il est temps cette deuxième
lecture que le Sénat soutienne
clairement ce projet et le gouvernement
courageux qui le porte
en effet ce dernier a su prendre en
compte nos inquiétudes
quant au niveau de vie des retraités les
plus modestes puisque madame la ministre
nous l'a rappelé tout à l'heure a fait
des propositions fortes qui ont été
largement salués
à mon tour je tiens à souligner les
signes positifs que représentent
l'augmentation de 50 euros de l'aide à
la complémentaire santé
pour les bénéficiaires de plus de 60 ans
et le doublement du minimum vieillesse
en 2014
et à encourager mes collègues à suivre
les avancées engagées par divers groupes
politiques à l'Assemblée le soutien du
groupe socialiste déjà acquis en
première lecture sera aujourd'hui
réaffirmé face à l'urgence d'agir notre
système actuel est à bout de souffle et
de financement le manque d'efficacité de
la réforme de 2010 censé assurer un
équilibre de long terme nous impose de
légiférer à nouveau afin de ne pas faire
porter à nos enfants et petits-enfants
le poids de l'indécision du passé c'est
donc bien une réforme ambitieuse que
nous soutenons aujourd'hui dans cette
hémicycle puisque sans les efforts
demandés à tous le déficit structurel de
notre système de retraite atteindrée 20
milliards d'euros en 2020 face à
l'augmentation continuelle de
l'espérance de vie conjuguée aux effets
du baby-boom
dans le contexte de crise le
gouvernement a établi un projet
équilibré qui requiert la participation
de tous actif comme retraités salariés
comme entreprise privée comme public
nous choisissons aujourd'hui les refuser
l'immobilisme en menant de front des
mesures d'urgence et en décidant des
solutions de long terme articulées
notamment autour du pilotage lesquels
permettront de sauver notre système basé
sur la solidarité pour autant tout comme
la ministre des Affaires sociales nous
avons envie d'aller plus loin
en améliorant la situation de nos
concitoyens les plus vulnérables c'est
en ce sens que ce projet de loi
s'adresse aux femmes aux handicapés et à
leurs aidants familiaux aux actifs à
carrière heurtés au monde agricole en
leur accordant les droits dont ils
étaient jusque-là privés
il est de notre devoir de mettre fin à
des situations
d'injustice créé par notre modèle et de
faire évoluer notre système selon les
réalités sociales actuelles ce nouveau
souffle de justice s'illustre
parfaitement dans la reconnaissance et
l'accompagnement de la pénibilité que
permet ce texte et que refuser
d'accomplir les précédents gouvernement
il démontre ainsi qu'il n'est pas
impossible
d'harmoniser prévention et réparation
ainsi comme la teste ce dernier exemple
l'ambition de ce texte n'est pas
d'opposé mais bien de réactiver et de
réaffirmer la solidarité entre tous pour
faire triompher notre système et
s'assurer de sa pérennité réformer le
système de justice ne doit pas forcément
se faire dans la douleur
comme ce fut le cas en 2010 mais c'est
la terre socialiste aborde donc cette
nouvelle lecture avec l'espoir que le
dialogue permettra au soutien apporté à
ce texte de grandir pour parvenir à
garantir l'avenir et la justice de notre
système de retraite je remercie
merci
la discussion générale est close madame
la ministre vous souhaitez répondre aux
orateurs
nous allons donc
aborder le premier amendement de
l'article premier l'amendement 21 qui le
présente c'est Madame
fake
c'était maintenant mes chers collègues
et de nature principalement
rédactionnelle bien qu'il est pour effet
de rappeler la nature de notre régime de
retraite non seulement celle celui-ci
est à cotisation définie mais il est
également répartition c'est-à-dire que
les générations sont liées entre elles
notre système de retraite repose en
effet sur une solidarité entre les
jeunes salariés et les actifs qui
cotisent pour financer et les pensions
des retraités il est retraités qui se
retirent du marché du travail de telle
sorte que les jeunes puissent eux y
entrer nous souhaitons pas cet
amendement que la loi conforte ce
système en précisant que les générations
sont unies entre elles proposition qui
en première lecture avait été retenue
par le Sénat il y avait bénéficié d'un
avis favorable de notre rapporteur
merci avez du gouvernement
favorable je mets donc on voit cet
amendement quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
avec contraire il est adopté amendement
numéro 2 monsieur Cardou
le ministre
c'est un amendement qui
s'inscrit après l'article 4 et qui est
dans le droit fil des quelques mots que
j'ai prononcés en propos liminaire
concernant l'affirmation d'un des trois
niveaux de trois échelons de retraite en
France donc le premier celui de la
répartition constitué des régimes
obligatoires de base et complémentaires
le deuxième constitué de régime de
retraite supplémentaire collectif dédié
à certaines professions préfont pour les
fonctionnaires contre un Madelin pour
les indépendants ou installer au niveau
de l'entreprise et puis le troisième
celui de l'épargne retraite individuel
qui passe soit par un PERP plan
d'épargne retraite populaire soit par un
contrat d'assurance vie et une formule
de capitalisation comme le PERCO plan
des pins de retraite collectif mise en
place comme le père par la réforme
Fillon donc ce sont deux outils qui sont
peut utiliser très peu développé et donc
notre volonté d'affirmer dans le texte
par cet amendement tout l'avenir qui a
une retraite par capitalisation en
complément de la retraite par
répartition et en soulignant comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le faire déjà plusieurs
reprises que nous avons devant nous le
financement de la dépendance et que très
probablement et bien dans ce financement
d'un fondant la dépendance il faudra
instiller une petite dose de
capitalisation auprès d'organismes
privés donc ce serait ouvrir la voie un
tel mécanisme merci avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur
le Président Madame
précisé d'abord que tous les amendements
qui nous sont présentés aujourd'hui
l'ont déjà été en première lecture par
notre assemblée donc vous comprendrez
bien que je mettrai les mêmes avis avec
la Commission a émis les mêmes avis sur
cet amendement numéro 2 qui porte sur
l'existence des trois étages du système
de retraite c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci Amélie du gouvernement
madame la ministre évidemment
défavorable défavorables je vais donc
mettre au bois cet amendement quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
quels sont ceux qui sont pour adopter
l'amendement de Monsieur Cardou
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté amendement 23 kilos
défend madame Cohen
là encore mes chers collègues il s'agit
d'un amendement que nous avions présenté
en première lecture et qui avait été
adopté en effet c'est alinéa prévoit que
les assurés bénéficient d'un traitement
équitable au regard de la durée de la
retraite comme du montant de leur
pension or ce traitement équitable doit
être la réalité quel que soit
l'espérance de vie qui reste aux
salariés que celui-ci soit ou non en
bonne santé maintenir cette disposition
reviendrait à dire à contrario que le
traitement pourrait être inéquitable en
fonction de la qualité de l'espérance de
vie des salariés nous avions eu en
première lecture un débat intéressant
sur le fait de savoir et d'ailleurs je
remercie notre collègue Catherine
Génisson de nous avoir soutenu en ce
sens s'il fallait que la loi précise ou
non que tout soit mis en oeuvre pour
garantir à nos concitoyens l'allongement
de leur espérance de vie en bonne santé
je crois que cela a toute sa place dans
la loi puisqu'il s'agit chacun leur a
compris de distinguer deux sujets
l'espérance de vie qui est un enjeu de
santé publique c'est un contestable et
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé qui
soulève la question de la pénibilité des
conditions de travail tel est le sens de
cet amendement qui avait été compris
majoritairement par notre Haute
Assemblée merci quelle est la vie de la
commission madame le rapporteur monsieur
le Président Madame la ministre mes
chers collègues la vie de la commission
est identique à la vie qui avait été
émis en première lecture on est bien là
sur un objectif de politique de santé
publique et non pas sur un objectif du
système de retraite c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci avis du gouvernement
Madame le Ministre défavorable merci je
le mets aux voix qu'elles sont ceux qui
sont pour l'adoption de l'amendement 23
avis contraire
et bien nous allons le faire par
acide-boue quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption de l'amendement de Madame
Cohen
avis contraire
il est adopté
amendement 3 qu'il présente monsieur
Cardou
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre il s'agit de compléter la ligne
assise de l'article 1er en affichant des
objectifs de lisibilité de transparence
donc bien sûr il est souhaitable d'avoir
des objectifs de lisibilité transparence
pour les règles actuelles du système de
retraite mais surtout avec l'évolution
telle qu'elle s'affiche devant nous et
nous semble indispensable que les
assurés est une bonne visibilité sur les
règles futures du système tel qu'elle
s'appliqueront au moment de leur départ
à la retraite donc le corps qui joue
parfaitement son rôle le rappelle d'une
manière continue et nous souhaitons
inscrire cette perspective dans la loi
de manière à ce qu'elle soit intangible
merci avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur oui monsieur le président
madame la ministre vous avez parlé
d'objectif de lisibilité et de
transparence mon cher collègue ils sont
pris en compte par l'article 26 du
projet de loi qui met en oeuvre un droit
à l'information et qui crée le compte
individuel de retraite en ligne c'est
donc un avis défavorable sur cet
amendement merci même à vie du
gouvernement mais ma vie pour les mêmes
raisons merci beaucoup je le mets au
vois quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
il n'est pas adopté amendement numéro 20
madame Cohen
et constant sur le sujet de l'égalité
salariale en ce sens que nous souhaitons
comme beaucoup d'ailleurs de mes
collègues soit mis en œuvre tout ce
qu'il est possible de mettre en œuvre et
pour que on assiste à une fin des
inégalités de salaire de niveau de vie
et de retraite dans les femmes sont
victimes vous le savez sur trois
retraités pauvres de son des femmes
cette statistiques révélatrice de la
condition d'une partie de la population
féminine française devrait à elle seule
justifier me semble-t-il l'adoption du
présent amendement en effet si nous
souscrivons à la portée philosophique de
cet article premier en matière d'égalité
de retraites entre les femmes et les
hommes nous nous demandons comment y
parvenir si rien n'est mis en oeuvre
pour tarir le problème à la source à
savoir dans le monde du travail ou le
salaire des femmes est souvent
injustement inférieur aux rémunération
des hommes cette préoccupation nous a
conduit à déposer cet amendement qui je
tiens à le préciser avait fait l'objet
en première lecture d'un vote favorable
de notre
merci avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur
le président madame la ministre ma chère
collègue vous savez que on parle de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
dans l'article alinéa 6 donc c'est un
amendement nous semble redondant nous
l'avions déjà dit donc c'est une demande
de retraite sinon c'est un avis
défavorable merci il y avait du
gouvernement défavorable défavorable je
le mets au bois qu'elles sont ceux qui
sont pour son adoption
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté
amendement 22 madame Cohen non madame
Pasquier
spécificités de notre modèle social et
son financement qui repose sur des
cotisations sociales prélevées sur la
valeur ajoutée mise en commun au sein
d'un organisme n'appartenant pas à
l'état mais aux travailleurs eux-mêmes
personne n'est donc propriétaire de ses
cotisations et des quatre branches qui
constituent la sûreté sociale obéissent
à des règles assurantielles très
différentes de celles qui sont
applicables au secteur marchand
nous avons d'ailleurs eu l'occasion de
rappeler que notre système de retraite
que certains voudraient voir plus encore
ouvrir à la concurrence et à la
capitalisation repose sur la solidarité
et même pour être plus précis sur
différents niveaux de solidarité des
générations entre elles comme de la même
génération entre celles et ceux qui
travaillent et celles et ceux qui sont
privés d'emploi or il nous apparaît
important de rappeler dans quel contexte
dans quel cadre s'inscrit cette
solidarité c'est à dire dans une mise en
commun de prélèvements opérés sur le
travail de telle sorte que les retraites
constituent aujourd'hui des éléments de
rémunération différé financés par les
cotisations sociales ce mécanisme de
solidarité intergénérationnelle mais
ainsi en place une boucle vertueuse
qui ne permettent que ne permettent pas
des retraites par capitalisation
lesquelles à l'inverse individualise à
l'extrême empêchant ainsi toute
solidarité alors tout cela n'est
possible qu'à la condition que les
jeunes générations puissent trouver
après leurs études des débouchés dans la
vie active c'est ce que cet amendement
est rappelé en précisant que la
solidarité intergénérationnelle passe
par une politique de l'emploi favorisant
notamment l'intégration sociale et
professionnelle des jeunes le
remplacement des salariés partant en
retraite la reconnaissance des
qualifications initiales et acquise la
prise en compte de la pénibilité des
tâches et des métiers
si il y avait de la Commission
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre cet amendement qui vise à
préciser les caractéristiques d'une
politique d'emploi
étant au service d'une solidarité
intergénérationnelle cet amendement
avait été en première lecture avec
obtenu un avis favorable donc en
cohérence avec cela je vous propose un
avis favorable de la commission
un avis défavorable monsieur le
Président je comprends bien les
objectifs qui sont poursuivis et
d'ailleurs je ne peux qu'il souscrire et
le gouvernement ne peut que souscrire
aux objectifs qui sont posés par cet
amendement lorsque par exemple il fait
référence à la reconnaissance des
qualifications initiales et acquises ou
à une politique de l'emploi qui soit
active néanmoins cela n'a pas avoir avec
l'organisation d'un système de retraite
c'est à dire que l'on peut poursuivre
des objectifs qui sont ainsi fixés mais
dans un cadre qui n'est pas celui de
l'équilibre et de l'organisation de
notre système de retraite on entre soit
dans trop de précisions soit dans des
contraintes eu égard à un système
d'organisation de la protection sociale
qui n'ont pas avoir avec les objectifs
poursuivis par cette loi donc je donne
un avis défavorable
merci je le mets au bois quelles sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire
il est adopté
quatre amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune la maman numéro 1
monsieur vandalenberg
merci monsieur le Président Madame
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est amendement et celui qui nous tient
le plus à cœur mais je serai bref
puisque tout à l'heure je l'ai exposé
dans le la discussion générale
le Sénat je le rappelle l'avait adopté
en première lecture il change totalement
l'orientation et la philosophie de la
réforme et il fixe un calendrier pour sa
mise en œuvre pour la mise en œuvre
d'une réforme systémique et non
seulement paramétrique du système de
retraite donc pour nous le débat
national doit donc avoir lieu et la mise
en oeuvre programmée sachant que à nos
yeux seule la réforme systémique est
juste totalement transparente de nature
à garantir la pérennité financière
l'équité et la justice du système par
répartition donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous le redéposons aujourd'hui
merci amendement 55 monsieur Tropéano
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre cela a été dit à maintes
reprises notre système de retraite est
particulièrement complexe pour y mettre
fin nous vous proposons de réfléchir à
la mise en place de d'une réforme
systémique dans une société en pleine
mutation la question des retraites ne
peut pas être éternellement abordé sous
le seul angle paramétrique le groupe
RDSE est convaincu qu'une telle réforme
est inévitable et l'appel de ses vœux de
plus plusieurs années lors de la réforme
de 2019 nous avions souhaité qu'une
réflexion nationale s'organisée elle
aurait dû d'ailleurs avoir lieu au cours
du premier semestre 2013 selon un
sondage CSA publié en septembre dernier
plus de 8 Français sur 10 se disent
inquiets pour leur retraite il faut leur
donner confiance le passage un système
de retraite par point mais très fin à
l'opacité du système actuel et serait de
ce fait de mieux compris mieux accepté
par l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
il aurait aussi surtout l'avantage de la
garantir la pérennité financière
plusieurs rapports nous invitent ainsi
en 2010 dans un rapport d'information de
la mission d'évaluation et de contrôle
de la sécurité sociale doit vous étiez
signataire ma cosignatière madame la
rapporteur appelé de ses vœux une
réforme plus profonde dans l'objectif
serait de restaurer la confiance des
assurés et notamment des plus jeunes
dans le système de retraite la Mexx
proposait précisément je cite la mise en
place à terme d'un régime de base par
point qui devrait revêtir le caractère
le plus universel possible la même année
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
dans ce septième rapport montrer que le
passage régime par point ou en compte
notionnel était techniquement possible
et permettait notamment d'intégrer des
dispositifs de solidarité c'est à ce
titre que nous garantirons l'avenir de
notre système de retraite
merci
l'amendement 56 n'est pas défendu un
moment 4 monsieur Cardou
le Président Madame le Ministre donc
nous en sommes dans le droit fil des
trois amendements présentés précédemment
et dans ce que j'ai dit dans dans la
discussion générale
nous souhaitons qu'un débat national en
vue d'une réforme systémique au premier
semestre 2015 soit établi puisque comme
cela était souligné la plupart des
Français le souhaitent et que nous
voudrions voir mettre en place une
retraite par point et une convergence
des régimes publics privés
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame le rapporteur
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je crois qu'on va pas reprendre le débat
qui a eu lieu en première lecture
nous avons la conviction que la réforme
que vous proposez
ne règle rien au problème de la
pérennité de notre système de retraite
la commission a donc émis un avis
défavorable sur ses amendements merci
avis du gouvernement madame la ministre
merci je vais le mettre au voie en
commençant par le numéro 1 monsieur des
Essarts pour explication de vote
est important et en particulier le les
amendements proposés en particulier le
l'amendement numéro 1 remet en cause la
philosophie du système par répartition
donc tout d'abord
où il organise différemment on va rester
sur ce point
en tout cas
nous les écologistes on a on est pour
une réforme systémique dans le sens que
dans notre congrès il y a 15 jours on a
réaffirmé fortement
notre attachement à un revenu universel
de base
de l'enfance à la fin de vie quel que
soit les conditions
de revenus après la compensation parce
qu'on va dire quelqu'un qui a un revenu
important va en bénéficier mais la
compensation c'est évidemment les
monsieur Cardou va m'approuver une
fiscalité plus importante pour les
salaires les plus élevés mais il aura
quand même bénéficié de cela
donc nous nous sommes quand même pour
une solidarité nationale et pas
simplement pour un système assurantiel
et que il y a une base forfaitaire qui
est de la solidarité nationale fortement
affirmée et que tous nos retraites
toutes les pensions ne soient pas basées
sur le sol
revenus qu'on a eu au cours de sa
carrière mais mon cher collègue donc on
est pas tout à fait en philosophie avec
votre amendement puisqu'on est quand
même pour une partie beaucoup plus fixe
de solidarité nationale
vous n'allez pas assez loin chers
collègues parce que vous laissez les
deux options système notionnel et
système à points alors que je vous sens
le rapprochement géographique peut-être
de nous banc fait que je crois savoir
que vous êtes vous plus favorable à un
système à point et je crois qu'on
gagnerait en clarté dans un débat
hémicycle ce que le système de sonnel
c'est un système c'est une génération à
côté des étangs on récupère en tenant
compte de l'actualisation de coût de la
vie à plus tard 30 ans 40 ans plus tard
cette génération récupère la même somme
je crois que c'est ça le système suédois
qui a un système très compliqué très
soumis aux aléas économiques qui bougent
beaucoup c'est quand même plus simple à
ce niveau-là qu'il y a un système de
répartition qui est décidée par la
représentation nationale en tenant
compte et bien de la part qu'on attribue
pour les retraités
le système par point un avantage par
contre c'est que donne c'est un système
où il y a des carrières de plus en plus
interrompues qui ne sont pas fixes ou on
fait que maintenant du privé et ensuite
du public et on peut même revenir il y a
beaucoup de précarité et le système
danuité avec des trimestres est un
système assez lourd par après qui
correspond pas toujours au système de la
précarité mais la crainte que nous avons
avec le système par point c'est que ça
peut ouvrir la voie
à des systèmes privés et ce n'est plus
l'état qui serait le garantie mais
puisqu'on est par point bien on peut
très bien à un moment à vous vous faites
le coup assez souvent
on va le priver fera les mêmes rendra
les mêmes services que le public
c'est pas oui
oui mes amis
parfois ce sont mes amis parfois au
contraire mais mes adversaires
politiques vous vous êtes en général mes
amis ce sont le dossier retraite
donc le système j'en finis monsieur le
Président le système par point peut
glisser vers un système d'assurance
privé et c'est ce que nous craignons par
contre et là c'est quand même l'intérêt
du test comme la rapporter comme la dit
notre rapporteur c'est qu'il y a une
prise en compte de plus en plus dans ce
projet de loi justement de des périodes
fragmentées de carrière de la précarité
donc on va dans le bon sens lorsque
justement on rend plus souple le système
de comptabilité des heures travaillées
le système de revenus donc pour le
moment chers collègues même s'il est
utile que la représentation nationale et
ce débat sur le système par point sur le
système forfaitaire de solidarité
nationale comment calculer
déjà le système assurantiel il
mériterait cela mériterait un grand
débat mais pour le moment c'est
prématuré et n'aurait affirmons notre
soutien pour ce projet de loi au système
par répartition mais et voilà pourquoi
nous ne pouvons pas voter votre
abonnement en l'état
merci je vais donc mettre monsieur
vandalenberg
madame Debré oui merci monsieur le
Président Madame le ministre mes chers
collègues nous voterons l'amendement de
Monsieur vallanberg puisque nous
demandons un débat et une réforme
systémique alors j'entends ce que dit
mon collègue de Cesars pour autant rien
n'empêche dans les réflexions d'avoir un
socle de solidarité nous y sommes
effectivement très attachés et avoir
comme d'autres pays l'ont fait un
système par point complémentaire ça
c'est la première chose vous avez dit
que ça tient ça pourrait aider à tenir
compte des périodes fragmentées mais
j'irai plus loin ça aidera aussi à
calculer la pénibilité aujourd'hui on
voit bien que c'est extrêmement
difficile d'avoir les critères exacts
pour la pénibilité et le système par
point sera beaucoup plus maniable et
facile pour justement tenir compte de la
pénibilité et pour toutes ces questions
et nous l'avions dit dans la précédente
majorité lorsque nous étions nous étions
en charge le gouvernement précédent nous
avions déjà demandé une réforme
systémique ou une très forte réflexion
sur la réforme systémique et c'est pour
cette raison que nous voterons que le
groupe UMP votera l'amendement de
Monsieur valarenberg
merci Monsieur Madame Berg
juste un mot monsieur le Président c'est
pour répondre à mon ami Jean de Cesar je
crois que il démontre si c'était
nécessaire de la nécessité du débat
national parce que c'est un système par
répartition il n'y a aucune menace du
privé dans cette affaire on s'inscrit
parfaitement dans le système et
s'il y a effectivement dans le rapport
du corps une alternative entre les
comptes nationales et le point et les
régimes par point je suis pour ma part
plutôt favorable au régime par point
mais ça ouvre le débat justement il faut
bien qu'il y ait des alternatives dans
un débat pour que celui-ci est
réellement lieu donc merci Isabelle
Debré de soutenir cet amendement je
pense que c'est l'avenir et moi je donne
rendez-vous à 2017 vous verrez qu'en
2017 tout le monde se rejoindra sur la
nécessité pour pérenniser le système par
répartition
d'une réforme systémique par point
merci je vais donc mettre au revoir
l'amendement numéro 1 à madame le
rapporteur
une précision par rapport cet amendement
numéro un parce que j'entends des choses
qui ne sont pas tout à fait vrai
puisque il ne s'agit pas à travers cet
amendement d'engager une réflexion mais
je lis afin d'assurer la pérennité
financière et l'équilibre entre les
générations du système de retraite par
répartition ainsi que son équité et sa
transparence une réforme systémique et
mise en oeuvre à compter du 1er
septembre 2017 donc je confirme un avis
défavorable
merci je vais donc le mettre au bois et
je suis Madame Cohen
scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos et nous allons procéder
au dépouillement
résultat du scrutin 104 sur l'amendement
numéro 1 du groupe ude nombre de votants
347 nombre de suffrages exprimés 329
pour l'adoption 170 contre 159 le Sénat
a donc adopté l'amendement numéro 1 et
en conséquence donc les trois autres
amendements tombent et je vais donc
mettre voilà l'article premier quels
sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
d'articles premier
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté
article 2 avec trois amendements en
discussion commune trois amendements
identique le premier rendement numéro 5
de Monsieur Cardou
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre collègues donc
l'effet allusion une fois de plus on
vous propose liminaires du choix fait
par le gouvernement d'allonger la durée
des cotisations d'un trimestre tous les
trois générations à compter de mes 2020
et nous estimons que c'est une mesure
insuffisante et injuste procédé comme le
fait le gouvernement s'est choisi la
mesure d'allongement du travail à la
fois la plus néfaste pour le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités la moins lisible
pour les assurer et la moins honnête à
l'égard des jeunes générations si la
durée de cotisation passe à 43 ans celui
qui a recommencé de travailler à 23 ans
ne pourra partir qu'à 66 ans alors que
l'âge légal elle sera toujours fixée à
62 ans c'est ce que j'ai pu qualifier de
mesure hypocrites dont mon propos
d'intervention c'est donc prendre le
risque des Français par des étages là
avec une décote et donc une baisse
significative du niveau de leur pension
c'est également l'option la moins
efficace financièrement puisque l'on
sait qu'à l'horizon 2030 le scénario
privilégié par le gouvernement évoque
une économie de 2,7 milliards d'euros
l'augmentation ne serait-ce que d'un an
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
qui passerait à 63 ans pour la
génération 1962 permettrait une économie
de 3,6 milliards d'euros pour le régime
général et de 5,3 milliards d'euros tout
régime confondu selon l'adresse
merci amendement 24 qui défend madame
Cohen
cet amendement a pour objet de supprimer
l'article 2 de ce projet de loi qui
constitue pour nous l'une des mesures
les plus injustes cette réforme et qui
va à l'encontre du monde du travail et
des salariés et nous semble
effectivement injuste aujourd'hui de
faire le choix qui est celui de faire
payer les salariés d'aujourd'hui les
retraités de demain d'autant que nous
l'avons déjà dit si l'adoption de cet
article permettrait de réduire le
déficit de la CNAV elle pèsera sur le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités qui
devront supporter les décotes et des
décotes aggravées ce qui ne sera pas
évidemment sans incidence sur la
consommation la relance ni même sur
d'autres éléments de dépenses publiques
je pense d'ailleurs aux dépenses
sociales supportées par les départements
qui elles vont comme les cons de
lunédique d'être sérieusement mis à
contribution pour mémoire les efforts
des salariés représentent avec ce seul
article 5,4 milliards d'euros quand les
patrons voient aboutir une vieille
revendications lors des engagement
progressif et continue du financement de
la branche famille nous sommes au niveau
de notre groupe le groupe cerci opposé à
cette mesure opposée à se basculement de
financement de notre système de
protection sociale du travail vers les
ménages nous sommes également opposés à
un article qui s'il devait être mis en
œuvre pèserait d'autant plus lourd pour
les plus modestes donc pour les femmes
qui sont celles qui subissent déjà des
retraites largement amputées je ne
développerai pas puisque nous avons eu
l'occasion en première lecture d'en
parler abondamment donc c'est pour
toutes ces raisons que nous proposons la
suppression de cet article merci
amendement 39 monsieur des Essarts
oui bien nous également nous proposons
la suppression de cet article qui
propose
l'augmentation progressive jusqu'à 43
ans de la durée minimale de cotisations
pour liquider une pension à taux plein
alors ce n'est pas une posture cher ami
chers collègues
socialiste comme vous le disiez c'est
une idée fondamentale des écologistes de
dire qu'aujourd'hui et bien pour qu'on
travaille tous il faut travailler moins
et donc nous avons quand même une vision
de la société où aujourd'hui la
nécessité en période de ce production et
bien n'est pas de travailler toujours
plus mais au contraire de répartir le
travail entre les jeunes et les plus
anciens entre ceux qui n'ont pas ceux
qui en ont trop et que justement on doit
réfléchir aujourd'hui aux outils aux
méthodes de redistribution plutôt que de
vouloir donner du travail à ceux qui en
ont déjà et faire et ne pas favoriser
les jeunes qui n'en ont pas les
seigneurs qui n'ont pas et qui verront
que vous l'avez dit chers collègues du
groupe CRC et bien leur pension diminuée
parce qu'il n'obtiendront pas le nombre
de d'années de cotisations nécessaires
donc ce ne ce n'est pas aujourd'hui une
mesure de justice ce n'est pas une
mesure
anticipatrice de la société que nous
voulons créer aujourd'hui une société de
surproduction de trop grande
consommation et la planète ne s'en
sortira pas si l'on croit que l'on peut
toujours aller vers une croissance
infinie de
la production industrielle on doit
trouver dans l'état actuel des
ressources dans l'état actuel de de la
masse salariale nécessaire pour obtenir
un
satisfaire les besoins de notre société
on doit réaliser la redistribution dès
maintenant il ne faut pas courir après
un travail qu'il n'existe pas et on aura
dans quelques années et je pense que le
projet de loi va être adopté les mêmes
jeunes mentaux John au chômage les
seniors qui ne pourront pas trouver
d'emploi et des décotes des pensions
nous n'allons rien résoudre c'est une
mesure injuste et qui ne répond pas aux
enjeux d'aujourd'hui enjeux
environnementaux et sociaux
merci avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur oui monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
cet article 2
qui concerne l'allongement de la durée
d'assurance c'est extrêmement important
il est extrêmement important dans ce
projet de loi il est extrêmement
important pour atteindre l'objectif
d'équilibre financier de notre système
de retraite par répartition
ces amendements visent donc à supprimer
cet article 2 et donc pour les raisons
que je viens d'évoquer la commission a
émis un avis défavorable
à ses trois amendements merci avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
gouvernement donne évidemment un avis
défavorable à cet amendement de assais
amendements de suppression c'est là un
article
essentiel de ce texte de loi que le
gouvernement j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire assume pleinement que j'assume
pleinement il s'agit de considérer que
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie
permet de travailler plus longtemps mais
que la
durée de cotisation demandée à chacun de
nos concitoyens doit tenir compte des
conditions dans lesquelles chacun est
amené à travailler c'est ce que nous
verrons dans d'autres articles et c'est
ce que j'ai rappelé tout à l'heure à la
tribune l'élément socle de ce texte de
loi d'un côté un effort l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation de l'autre
l'adaptation de cet effort en fonction
des réalités de la vie professionnelle
je profite d'ailleurs de l'occasion qui
m'est ainsi donné
de souligner que la démarche qui a été
engagée par le gouvernement français et
qui a commencé en 2012 avec la
présentation l'adoption d'un décret
permettant de revenir à un départ
anticipé à la retraite à 60 ans pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler jeune
relève de la même logique c'est-à-dire
un effort est demandé une règle est
fixée mais une prise en compte de
situations particulières et réalisée que
cette logique là est aujourd'hui reprise
par le gouvernement de coalition en
Allemagne et je ne peux que me réjouir
de voir que en Allemagne grâce à la
démarche des sociaux-démocrates et bien
la coalition au pouvoir a adopté une
logique qui est exactement celle que
j'ai porté que j'ai poussé au cours des
derniers mois et à l'occasion de ce
texte et puisque en général nous
entendons des leçons venir
des bancs de l'opposition nous
conseillons d'aller regarder ce qui se
passe en Allemagne et bien j'en appelle
à chacun sur les bancs de cette
hémicycle regardez comment on peut
prendre exemple sur ce café la France
pour faire avancer les droits en matière
de retraite y compris dans des pays
européens voisins qui n'avaient pas la
même tradition ni la même politique que
la nôtre merci madame la ministre je
vais donc mettre vos voix ces trois
amendements que reçus la vie défavorable
de la commission et du gouvernement et
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe UMP et le groupe
écologiste
procéder au scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert
demande à voter le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin 105 sur les hommes
non identiques 5 24 et 39 nombre de
votants 347 nombre de suffrages exprimés
347 pour l'adoption 203 contre 144 le
Sénat a donc adopté ces trois
amendements identiques et en conséquence
les invendent dans 40 57 et 41 tombent
et l'article 2 est supprimé
je vais mettre voilà l'article 2 bis
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'article de bis
avis contraire
sur l'article de BIS il est adopté
article 3 et l'amendement 6 monsieur
Cardou
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre chers collègues j'ai eu
plusieurs à plusieurs reprises
l'occasion de dire que la grande
spécialité française était maintenant de
créer des structures qui s'empilent pour
établir des rapports et ce texte ne fait
pas exception à la règle puisque on crée
une énième entité qui sera chargé de
réfléchir sur l'évolution du régime de
retraite à travers ce comité de pilotage
des retraites que on veut nous faire
créer mais surtout avec la méthode pour
créer cet organisme et qui serait
composé de cinq experts j'avoue que j'ai
toujours des doutes sur ce que cache le
mot expert quand il est pas suivi de la
spécialité dont le président est nommé
en Conseil des ministres c'est encore
désolé de constater une tentative de
main mise du service de l'État et du
Gouvernement sur ce genre de comité et
ce qui plus simple assez sous tutelle du
Premier ministre donc plutôt faut créer
un énième comité de suivi il serait
certainement beaucoup plus profitable
d'élargir les missions du comité
d'alerte sur l'évolution des dépenses
d'assurance maladie actuellement placé
auprès de la commission des contes de la
sécurité sociale et d'en faire un comité
d'alerte sur les dépenses des risques
maladie et vieillesse responsable
d'alerte le gouvernement le Parlement en
cas de trajectoire défavorable des
comptes de l'assurance vieillesse la
création d'une nouvelle instance de
consultation une fois de plus ne se
justifie donc pas d'où cet amendement de
suppression merci avis de la commission
madame le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre mon cher collègue cet article 3
est important puisque
on se plaint toujours et suite au
précédent très fort de l'absence de
pilotage de notre système de retraite
donc cet article 3 qui crée un nouveau
dispositif de pilotage est important
vous supprimez vous proposez de le
supprimer c'est donc un avis défavorable
merci avis du gouvernement mais ma vie
et je le mets aux voix qu'elles sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
il n'est pas adopté amendement 42
monsieur des Essarts
puisse définir davantage la situation
des seniors en fin de carrière donc pour
que le corps coordonne les recherches
les fins de carrière et compilent les
données afin que nous puissions prendre
une décision toute connaissance de cause
merci de la commission
la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre
un avis défavorable monsieur le
Président il nous paraît nécessaire de
bien établir une différence entre ce qui
relève du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites en amont de toute politique
gouvernementale et ce qui est du ce qui
relève du comité de suivi y compris pour
l'emploi des seniors merci je vais donc
mettre à l'amendement 42 quels sont ceux
qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire
il est adopté le 58 tombe et nous en
arrivons au 43 de Monsieur des Essarts
c'est amendement vise à limiter les
conclusions du rapport du Comité
concernant l'augmentation de la durée
d'assurance vieillesse l'article 2 du
projet de loi prévoyant déjà un logement
de la durée de claudiation il convient
d'encadrer des à présent toute velléité
d'un nouvel d'un nouvel allongement vous
me direz nous ne l'avons pas voté ici au
Sénat mais sans doute que l'Assemblée
nationale va réhabiliter l'article 2 et
cet amendement encore tout son sens
c'est pour dans la prospective évitez et
vraiment vérifier que il est toujours
nécessaire d'aller plus loin parce que
si on regarde la référence de Madame la
Ministre tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire un
accord les sociaux-démocrates avec
le la droite allemande c'est ils vont
beaucoup plus loin dans la dans l'âge
des cotisations et dans les durées de
cotisation donc on est parti peut-être
pour
une augmentation encore de la durée des
cotisations donc c'est un garde-fou si
vous voulez
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame le rapporteur
monsieur le Président c'est un avis
défavorable de la commission merci même
avec du gouvernement défavorable merci
je le vois qu'elles sont ceux qui sont
pour son adoption
avec le contraire
il n'est pas adopté je mets au voie
l'article 3 quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 3
avis contraire
on va
le faire paracide debout quels sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption de l'article 3
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 4 avec 3
amendements identiques le 7 de Monsieur
Cardou c'est bien ça
oui monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre chers collègues c'est un une
fois de plus un amendement de
suppression de l'article 4 puisque
le l'objectif de l'ancienne majorité
était de sauvegarder le pouvoir d'achat
des retraités c'est pourquoi la réforme
de 2010 ne prévoyait pas d'augmenter la
CSG ni de désindexer les pensions et le
gouvernement actuel justifie cette
mesure en faisant référence au rapport
de la commission pour l'avenir des
retraites qui souligne que le niveau de
vie des retraités est aujourd'hui
comparable à celui des actifs sans que
pèse sur les premiers le risque en
matière d'emploi et de pouvoir d'achat
auquel sont confrontés les seconds et
notamment les plus jeunes d'entre eux
ont cette période de crise et de
croissance du chômage sauf que ces
retraités sont souvent dans l'état
actuel des choses des soutiens
financiers pour leurs enfants ou leurs
petits-enfants donc dans sa logique
habituelle le gouvernement préfère
ponctionner les retraités plutôt que de
faire face à la réalité la nécessité de
travailler plus longtemps pour répondre
aux objectifs démographiques que
personne ne peut contester plutôt que de
prendre des mesures courageux et j'y
reviens sur l'allongement du temps de
travail la relance de l'emploi et la
compétitivité des entreprises le
gouvernement fait le choix de baisser le
pouvoir des chats donc baisse le pouvoir
d'achat dit forcément aussi baisse de
consommation et baisse de chiffre
d'affaires pour les entreprises et là il
s'agit d'un effort substantiel puisque
d'ici 2020 par le biais de cet article
il financeront la réforme à hauteur de
2,7 milliards d'euros ce qui n'est pas
rien d'une telle somme injectée d'un
circuit économique du pays
merci
un moment 25 madame Pasquet
l'article 4 est sans doute l'un des plus
emblématiques du présent texte puisqu’il
opère sur les retraités une fonction de
plusieurs millions d'euros prenant la
forme d'un gel temporaire des pensions
ainsi pendant 6 mois les retraités
supporteront une diminution de leur
pouvoir d'achat et devront faire face
coûte que coûte à l'augmentation des
dépenses courantes contraintes comme
celles liées à la fourniture de gaz et
d'électricité les dépenses de transport
d'alimentation les mutuelles les
assurances logements et des loyers cette
mesure est particulièrement injuste et
ce malgré des annonces faites par Madame
la Ministre de procéder et ne double
revalorisation de la SPA un peu comme si
les retraités qui touchent à peine plus
de 800 euros de retraite par mois
pouvait être considérés comme des
lentilles pour qui le gel des pensions
pourrait être sans conséquence d'autant
que vous le savez les retraités ont subi
l'année dernière pour la première fois
une taxe sur leur retraite destinée à
financer la sécurité sociale
mais certaines d'entre eux devront
également faire face là encore pour la
première fois à l'imposition sur le
revenu ainsi qu'à la suppression des
droits connexes liés à leur statut
fiscal passé
merci
amendement 44 monsieur des Essarts
car cet article nous propose de reporter
la revalorisation des pensions en
fonction de la fonction de six mois en
la fixant désormais au premier octobre
de chaque année il s'agit d'une des
mesures importantes du financement de ce
projet puisque son attendus des
économies de 800 millions dès 2014 et de
1,9 milliards en 2020 bien sûr nous
saluons l'initiative du Premier ministre
de revaloriser deux fois le minimum
vieillesse en 2014 et d'augmenter de 50
euros LED à l'acquisition d'une
complémentaire santé pour les plus de 60
ans disposons disposant d'une retraite
inférieure à 960 967 euros néanmoins
nous contestons le principe même du
décalage de revalorisation et de la
justice qu'il contient envers des
populations aux faibles revenus
certes la mesure exclut les
bénéficiaires de l'ASPA mais sur les 1,6
millions de retraités qui se situe sous
le seuil de pauvreté seul 600
000 bénéfices bénéficient de la SPA et
nous sommes donc particulièrement
injustes de mettre en place une mesure
qui touche un million de pensionnés déjà
défavorisés
le rapport décidait en 2010 a déjà
impacté les retraites reportées encore
la revalorisation c'est continuer de
mener une politique inéquitable et c'est
pourquoi nous vous proposons d'adopter
la suppression de cet article
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je rappelle que cet
article 4
insiste sur la nécessaire contribution
de tous
employeur salarié et retraités à
l'objectif
d'équilibre financier garantissant la
pérennisation et la pérennité de notre
système de retraite les trois
amendements qui nous sont proposés
visent à supprimer cet article 4 c'est
donc un avis défavorable merci avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
avis défavorable monsieur le Président
je veux rappeler à mon tour que c'est un
article qui fixe le principe d'une
contribution à l'effort nécessaire de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens à travers
une contribution des retraités pour
tenir compte de la situation des
retraités en situation modeste le
gouvernement a pris une série de mesures
d'abord il a indiqué que les
bénéficiaires de la location de
solidarité pour les personnes âgées ne
seraient pas concernés par le report de
l'indexation de leur retraite dans un
deuxième temps le gouvernement a ajouté
que ces mêmes bénéficiaires de l'ASPA
pourrait
te compter sur une double revalorisation
de leur retraite l'année prochaine ce
qui équivaut donc à un coup de pouce en
termes de pouvoir d'achat tout à fait
significatif et enfin pour répondre à la
situation
évoqué par de nombreux parlementaires
qui concernaient les retraités au-dessus
va disposant de revenus au dessus de la
location de solidarité pour personnes
âgées et en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
donc environ entre
780 euros et
980 euros à quelque chose près et bien
il a été décidé de revaloriser le
montant de l'aide à la complémentaire
santé qui est versée assez personnes de
revalorisation de 50 euros ce qui
permettra d'atténuer voir d'annuler
complètement l'effort demandé pour les
retraites dans le cadre de cet article
donc le gouvernement a entendu les
préoccupations pour ce qui est du
pouvoir d'achat des retraités modestes
pour autant il faut que pour l'avenir de
notre système de retraite le principe de
d'une contribution de l'ensemble des
retraités puisse être reconnus notamment
vis-à-vis des plus jeunes de nos
concitoyens merci madame la ministre je
vais donc mettre au voie ces trois
amendements identiques et je suis saisi
de
scrutin public de la part du groupe UMP
et du groupe écologiste mais madame
Debré vous voulez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues bien
évidemment je voterai cette cette
amendement de suppression mais vous ne
permettrez Madame le Ministre de
m'adresser directement à vous puisque je
n'ai pas pu redéposer l'amendement qui
permettait au titulaire de la SPA donc
du minimum vieillesse de pouvoir garder
leur ASPA leur allocation pardon et
aussi qu'ils puissent travailler donc
qu'ils puissent cumuler leur allocation
avec des revenus d'activité c'est
possible aujourd'hui pour tous les
retraités sauf pour ceux qui ont le
minimum vieillesse c'est-à-dire je
voudrais expliquer entre autres à nos
collègues et à ceux qui nous écoutent
dans les tribunes qu'aujourd'hui une
personne qui touche moins de 800 euros
si elle travaille et qu'elle touche 100
euros non seulement l'État prend les
cotisations sur ces 100 euros mais en
plus retire ces 100 euros sur leur
minimum vieillesse je trouve ça
absolument injuste
je dirais même inadmissible dans notre
pays nous avons déposé une proposition
de loi qui a été
consignée par plus de 90 parlementaires
cette proposition de loi en janvier
dernier donc maintenant cela fait un an
a été votée à la quasi unanimité du
Sénat elle a été rejetée en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale
elle est revenue par voie d'amendement
dans ce projet de loi nous avions eu à
l'époque en janvier un avis de sagesse
de Madame la Ministre Delaunay et
qu'elle ne fut pas notre surprise dans
ce projet de loi d'avoir de votre part
Madame le Ministre un avis défavorable
malgré votre avis défavorable
tous nos collègues les socialistes ont
fait je le remercie une abstention
positive les Verts ont voté pour les
communistes ont voté contre mais avec
effectivement un argument en nous disant
qu'il préférait la revalorisation de
l'espace qu'un parlementaire ne peut pas
faire puisqu'il serait taxé de l'article
40 donc madame le ministre vous nous
dites que vous allez permettre au
titulaire de l'ASPA de pouvoir
travailler et que vous allez prendre
cette décision par voie réglementaire
et madame le ministre je crois que les
parlementaires que nous sommes c'est
nous aussi qui faisons la loi pourquoi
attendre aujourd'hui alors que il était
tellement simple de dire oui ça fait un
an que ces personnes attendent un an que
vous auriez pu prendre cette décision et
Monsieur de Cesars l'avait dit de façon
extrêmement
forte ferme puisqu'il avait soutenu cet
amendement je n'ai pas pu le redéposer
en vertu de l'entonnoir ce qu'on appelle
l'entonnoir dans notre dans notre jargon
parlementaire donc voilà le ministre des
personnes attendent c'est vrai que
l'ancien gouvernement avait augmenté la
SPA de 25% en 5 ans et malgré tout ça
n'est pas suffisant aujourd'hui Madame
le Ministre croyez-vous possible de
vivre avec moins de 800 euros par mois
et en plus d'empêcher ces personnes de
travailler or le droit du travail est un
droit fondamental dans notre pays on les
empêche de travailler ce qui vous
l'imaginait bien favorise le travail je
dirais
stimuler pour être poli et en plus de ça
c'est un manque de dignité de
reconnaissance pour ces personnes alors
madame le ministre on fait preuve là de
quelque chose d'indigne vis-à-vis de
cette personne et quelque chose d'un
digne vis-à-vis des parlementaires que
nous sommes cela fait un an que ces
personnes attendent et je dois
reconnaître que nous recevons des
courriers les personnes je ne vois
vraiment pas pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
nous avez donné un avis défavorable
après nous avons donné un avis de
sagesse j'avoue que une fois de plus le
gouvernement c'est une fois oui une fois
peut-être une fois non là vous vous êtes
engagé donc pouvez-vous aujourd'hui me
dire quand et comment vous autoriserez
et vous donnerez ce droit fondamental
aux personnes titulaires de la SPA de
pouvoir travailler de façon digne et de
leur donner vraiment un statut de
personnes à part entière et non pas des
retraités à part par rapport aux autres
je vous remercie merci Monsieur de
Essarts
oui enfin moi je m'associe à la demande
de ma collègue et là je crois que c'est
sur tous les bancs
c'est quand même aberrant on a les
pensionnés qui reçoivent les pensions
les plus importantes
ils peuvent travailler pour compléter le
revenu
ceux qui ont le moins
ils ne peuvent pas alors là
franchement faut expliquer parce que
c'est incompréhensible
la mesure ça serait de dire personne ne
travaille parce que il y a un revenu
c'est un peu la position qui est
défendue au moins par un groupe ici
c'est à dire que on a la pension elle
doit être suffisamment correcte pour
qu'on puisse en vivre et il n'y a pas
besoin de travailler bon mais permettre
à ceux
qui ont la pension la plus élevée de
pouvoir compléter leurs revenus
et ceux qui n'auront qui ont justement
la pension la plus faible qui ont besoin
justement par rapport aux difficultés
aujourd'hui et qui peuvent trouver un
dépannage fin des quelques heures on
leur interdit de le faire c'est
inexplicable alors on peut dire on peut
on peut avoir des divergences politiques
sur d'autres choses mais là c'est
incompréhensible donc on ne peut que
s'associer à la demande de bred pourquoi
cela
ne se met pas en place et rapidement
si Madame le Ministre
oui madame Debré j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de vous répondre et les indignations
sont sélectives en tout cas vous avez la
mémoire ou courte ou arrêter à quelques
mois en arrière parce que au fond on si
vraiment la situation est aussi injuste
que vous le dites il vous appartenait de
transformer la situation au cours des
longues années au cours desquelles vous
avez eu les responsabilités et le
pouvoir de le faire je vous ai indiqué
c'est la deuxième chose que je veux vous
dire madame la sénatrice c'est que ça
n'est quand même pas à une parlementaire
chevronnée comme vous êtes que je vais
expliquer la différence entre la loi et
le règlement et rappeler que cette
différence ne tient pas au bon vouloir
du gouvernement mais est inscrite dans
notre constitution et donc lorsque je
vous dis qu'une disposition est du
ressort réglementaire ça ne veut pas
dire que nous l'enlevons au droit de
regard des parlementaires ça veut
simplement dire qu'on regarde la
Constitution et des textes qui existent
aujourd'hui il appartient au
gouvernement de prendre ou de ne pas
prendre d'ailleurs mais de prendre un
décret pour faire évoluer la situation
troisièmement je vous ai indiqué et je
maintiens que le gouvernement allait
prendre un décret pour permettre que la
situation actuelle évolue situation
monsieur le sénateur des Essarts qui
n'est pas caractérisé par le fait qu'il
y aurait une interdiction de travailler
pour les bénéficiaires de l'ASPA mais
une non incitation à travailler ce qui
n'est pas exactement la même chose le
résultat est plutôt celui qui indiquait
d'ailleurs madame Debré c'est que
certains de ces bénéficiaires de la SPA
peuvent être incités soit à ne pas
travailler pour améliorer leur situation
soit le faire dans des conditions que le
gouvernement ne peut évidemment pas
soutenir puisque ce sont des personnes
qui ont à ce moment là tendance à se
tourner vers le travail dissimulé nous
sommes actuellement en train de oui ne
vous froncez les sourcils on a si
lorsque l'on travaille on n'a pas de
rémunération supplémentaire par rapport
à la situation antérieure on est amené à
travailler au noir comme on dit de façon
très simple ça s'appelle du travail
dissimulé travail au noir plutôt que de
travailler de façon déclarée nous sommes
actuellement dans les concertations pour
déterminer le niveau d'activité
supplémentaire par rapport à la SPA qui
sera autorisé
dans le cadre de la nouvelle
réglementation c'est à dire que pardon
oui bah écoutez nous sommes en train de
faire les concertations donc en train de
déterminer une quelqu'un qui est
bénéficiaire de la SPA
quel niveau de revenu supplémentaires
par rapport à la SPA pourra-t-il cumuler
par rapport à son revenu
minimum la SPA étant un revenu minimum
et au-delà duquel on pourrait imaginer
une dégressivité nous sommes donc en
train de réaliser ces concertations je
l'ai dit un décret sera pris et donc un
décret sera pris
merci
je vais donc mettre au voie ces trois
amendements identiques et j'ai donc été
saisi d'un d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe UMP et le groupe
écologiste il va donc être procéder à la
mise en place du scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos et nous allons procéder
à son dépouillement
résultat du scrutin 106 sur les
amendements identiques 7 25 et 44 nombre
de votants 348 nombre de suffrages
exprimés 332 pour l'adoption 204 compte
128 le Sénat a donc adopté ces trois
amendements
identiques et en conséquence
l'amendement 26 et 45 tombent et
l'article 4 est supprimé
article 4 bis je vais le mettre au bois
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
du 4 bis
avis contraire il est adopté article 5
un amendement 27 c'est Madame Cohen qui
le défend
si vous le permettez je ferai le 28 en
même temps
afin de réduire donc la portée de cet
article 5 et donc de limiter les
dépenses supportées par les employeurs
en matière de prise en compte de la
pénibilité vous prévoyez que seuls les
salariés exposés un certain seuil
d'exposition à des facteurs à risque
seront pris en compte dans la fiche et
dans le compte personnel de prévention
de la pénibilité
chacun s'accorde à dire qu'en matière de
prévention de la pénibilité la notion de
seuil est à la fois complexe et
pénalisante pour un certain nombre de
travailleurs en effet le fait d'être en
dessous du seuil fixé par décret ne
signifient en rien que le travailleur
n'est pas dans une situation de danger
ou de réduction de son espérance de vie
en bonne santé à titre d'exemple
exposition des salariés en dessous du
seuil légal d'exposition à la
radioactivité ne signifie pas que
celle-ci n'a pas de conséquence sur
l'état de santé du salarié d'ailleurs
récemment une juridiction a connu la
responsabilité juridique de DF à la
suite de la mort d'un agent en charge de
l'entretien d'une centrale nucléaire
alors même que tous les relevés à tester
que celui-ci n'avait pas été exposé à
une dose de radioactivité excédant le
seuil légal cela a permis à la cour de
considérer que le décès de l'agent était
dû à une maladie professionnelle qui
plus elle a des finition même des seuils
n'est pas une chose aisée et vous vous
êtes opposé en première lecture comment
second lecture à l'Assemblée soit au
moins définis en lien avec les chsst
cela ne nous apparaît pas
judicieux raison pour laquelle dans la
perspective d'une véritable réparation
des préjudiciliés à la pénibilité nous
proposons de supprimer ces notions de
seuil quant à l'amendement 28 c'est
amendement effectivement pour objet de
veiller à ce que le CHSCT ou à défaut le
comité d'entreprise ou les délégués du
personnel soient obligatoirement associé
pour donc définir les postes à caractère
pénible en effet c'est les derniers
demeures aujourd'hui entre les mains des
employeurs dont on peut craindre que les
moins respectueux du droit du travail et
de la santé des salariés ne soit tentés
de minorer les risques figurants sur la
fiche afin de minorer par la suite leur
obligation en matière de prévention
voire d'indemnisation je vous remercie
merci Madame quelle est la vie de la
Commission sur ces deux amendements
madame la rapporteur
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
ce sont des avis défavorables qui sont
donnés à ces deux amendements parce que
le projet de loi donne une définition
des seuils d'exposition factor de
pénibilité c'est une vraie avancée le
dialogue après le vote de la loi
s'engagera entre l'administration et les
partenaires sociaux et je pense
important de préserver l'équilibre qui a
été atteint par l'Assemblée nationale
pour ce qui concerne le 28 et la
référence au CHSCT je pense que là
dessus il n'y a pas lieu d'aller plus
loin donc ce sont je le confirme des
avis défavorables qui sont donnés à ces
deux amendements merci avis du
gouvernement
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix ces
amendements commençant par le 27
rectifié quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
avec contraire
il n'est pas adopté même vote sur le 28
même vote amendement 46 monsieur des
Essarts
oui monsieur prudent j'ai fait une
défense rapide de cet amendement j'ai
bien compris que les caractères de
pénibilité il y a des facteurs objectifs
mais il est quand même intéressant que
dans l'entreprise le médecin du travail
qui a pu voir les dégâts causés par tel
utilisation de machine ou par tel poste
enfin sur tel poste puissent donner son
avis donc on souhaite par cet amendement
rajouter
la consultation des médecins de travail
dans la processus de définition des
postes à caractère pénible merci avis de
la commission
oui la commission pense sur cet
amendement qu'il faut préserver
l'équilibre du texte qui a été adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale et c'est donc
un avis défavorable du gouvernement
Madame le Ministre merci je vais donc
mettre ouvrir cet amendement quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire
il est adopté je vais donc mettre voilà
l'article 5 quels sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption d'article 5
avis contraire
il est adopté article 5 bis quels sont
ceux qui sont pour l'adoption de
l'article 5 bis
avec contraires il est adopté même vote
sur le 5 terre même vote nous en
arrivons à l'article 6 avec l'amendement
8 de Monsieur Cardou
collègue une fois de plus un article de
suppression concernant ce compte de
pénibilité qui comme j'ai souligné pose
de nombreux problèmes de financement
d'abord puisque il est fléché pour
coûter 2 milliards 5 2,5 milliards
d'euros en 2040 pour un rendement bien
inférieur des deux nouvelles cotisations
employeur la même date 800 millions
d'euros on ne sait pas comment
différencier sera financé donc ça me
paraît un peu hasardeuse de lancer une
réforme dont on ne maîtrise qu'un tiers
du financement
ce problème se double d'un autre
problème de hausse du coût du travail
d'ici 2020 les entreprises auront été
mises à contribution à hauteur de 2,2
milliards d'euros au titre de la hausse
des cotisations de 500 millions minimum
au titre de la pénibilité mentionnons
que ces contributions s'ajoutent aux
investissements déjà consentis par les
entreprises suis à la mise en place de
dispositifs pénibilité de 2010 un
problème d'application ensuite puisque
la création de ce compte risque
d'alourdir considérablement les charges
administratives des entreprises or les
TPE PME qui constituent la majeure
partie de notre tissu économique et qui
sont des gros créateurs d'emplois en
période de croissance ne dispose pas de
la ressource humaine pour tenir au jour
les fiches d'exposition de ces salariés
donc il va falloir qu'il fasse appel à
des conseils extérieurs qui mettra en
place ce compte et ses conseils
extérieurs se rémunèrent et cette
rémunération viendra s'ajouter au coût
direct du compte de pénibilité donc un
risque de multiplication de contentieux
enfin puisque la loi ne pourra empêcher
les différences d'appréciations entre
employeur et salarié quant à la
pénibilité des travaux enfin cette loi
vient se greffer sur les dispositifs
déjà existants la prise en charge de la
pénibilité sur la base d'une incapacité
constatée mise en place en 2010 et le
dispositif carrière long créé en 2003
qui compense bien souvent la pénibilité
du travail subie par les travailleurs
entrées très jeunes sur le marché du
travail ayant effectué des métiers dit
physique
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame le rapporteur
la vie de la commission monsieur le
Président est défavorable cet article 6
il est important puisqu'il crée le
compte personnel de prévention de la
pénibilité c'est un point fort du projet
de loi pour cette raison là nous ne
pouvons pas envisager sa suppression
merci avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre merci je vais donc mettre au
bois cet amendement 8 quelles sont ceux
qui sont pour son adoption
avec contraire
il n'est pas adopté amendement 59 qui
tombe l'amendement 53 qu'il défend
monsieur Tropéano
merci monsieur le Président Madame
ministre cette amendement bizarre en
obligatoire et non plus simplement
facultatif le fait de prévoir par
décrire un conseil d'état des
aménagements à l'acquisition de points
dans le code de prévention de la
pénibilité pour les personnes
âgées d'au moins 52 ans au premier
janvier 2015
merci avis de la commission madame il
favorable monsieur le président
merci je vais donc le mettre au bois
qu'elles sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire il est adopté amendement
29 rectifié madame Cohen
oui cet amendement a pour objet de
réintroduire une disposition que nous
avions proposée en première lecture que
le Sénat avait d'ailleurs adopté que les
députés n'ont pas retenu à savoir
l'instauration pour les salariés
affectés par des facteurs à risque et
demandant à bénéficier d'une formation
professionnelle d'une priorité de
reclassement en effet le fait de
permettre aux salariés de suivre une
formation de conduit pas automatiquement
à ce qu'elle issue de cette formation le
salarié ne soit plus exposé assez
facteurs il serait en effet anormal que
l'employeur est conscience des dangers
que le salarié subit en étant un poste
précis et qu'à l'issue de la formation
en fait ce salarié retrouve ce même
poste pour nous au groupe CRC la
finalité de ce compte individuel
pénibilité doit être de mettre un terme
ou tout du moins de réduire l'exposition
des salariés à des facteurs qui sont
nuisibles alors état de santé peuvent
par voie de conséquence réduire leur
espérance de vie en bonne santé c'est
pourquoi nous proposons que la formation
engagée par le salarié soit associée à
une priorité de reclassement de telle
sorte qu'il soit
transférés un poste non-exposé et
faisant appel aux compétences nouvelles
acquises par le salarié durant sa
période de formation
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
nous avions donné un avis favorable lors
de la première lecture donc c'est un
nouveau un avis favorable merci
le gouvernement donne un avis
défavorable comme il l'a fait en
première lecture
la question de l'accès à la formation
doit s'envisager dans le cadre plus
large de l'accès à la formation donc de
la loi
dite loi Annie ou sur la sécurisation du
marché du travail dans le cadre de la
loi à venir sur la formation
professionnelle mais il est extrêmement
difficile de définir des ordres de
priorité pour l'accès à la formation
alors même que des salariés peuvent se
retrouver dans le besoin d'une formation
même ce même si ils ne peuvent pas y
prétendre au titre de la loi retraite
mais tout simplement de leur accès à la
formation dans le cadre de leur parcours
professionnel donc le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas que l'on oppose les
salariés les uns aux autres dans leur
rapport à la formation et c'est dans le
cadre des textes portant sur l'accès à
la formation professionnelle qu'il nous
paraît nécessaire d'examiner cette
question donc avis défavorable merci je
le mets je vois qu'elles sont ceux qui
sont pour son adoption
avec le contraire
il est adopté l'amendement 47 a été
retirée amendement 30 rectifié madame
Cohen ou madame Pasquier
il est défendu quelle est la vie du
gouvernement de la Commission
c'est un avis défavorable monsieur le
Président gouvernement
merci je le mets aux voix qu'elles sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avec le contraire
on va le faire par assis debout quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avec
il n'est pas adopté 31 madame Cohen
toujours non madame Pasquier
cet amendement a fait l'objet d'un débat
intéressant première lecture qui s'est
conclut personne l'adoption raison pour
laquelle je ne doute pas qu'il soit de
nouveau adopté aujourd'hui en effet la
Linéa 45 de cet article 6 prévoit que
lorsque le différent il y a un désaccord
avec son employeur sur l'effectivité ou
l'ampleur de son exposition au facteur
de risque professionnel
mentionnés l'article l4161 1 le salarié
ne peut saisir la caisse d'une
réclamation relative à l'ouverture du
compte personnel de prévention de la
pénibilité ou au nombre de points
enregistrés sur celui-ci que si la
préalablement porté cette contestation
devant l'employeur dans des conditions
précisées par des crèmes conseils d'État
le salarié peut être assisté ou
représenté par une personne de son choix
appartenant au personnel de l'entreprise
pour autant l'entreprise peut être
dépourvue de représentants du personnel
des centres de factures de salariés
seuls face
ce qui n'est pas souhaitable c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous souhaitons
préciser que dans un tel cas le salarié
peut se faire accompagner par un
conseiller du salarié choisi sur une
liste dressée par l'autorité
administrative
merci avis de la commission madame a
rapporteur nous étions favorable à cet
amendement en première lecture nous
sommes toujours favorables merci avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
gouvernement était défavorable en
première lecture il est toujours
défavorable merci jeune mais on voit
qu'elles sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avec contraire il est adopté je mets au
voile article 6 quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 6
avis contraire
abstention il est adopté article 6 bis
quels sont ceux qui souhaitent adopter
l'article 6 bis
avis contraire
il est adopté
article 7 avec un amendement numéro 9
monsieur Cardou
oui parce que le Président Madame le
Ministre chers collègues
d'adaptation de l'article sec puisque
nous souhaitons par ce texte
faire intervenir un report d'application
du compte de prévention de la
possibilité de la pénibilité pour les
TPE et les PME comme avec les problèmes
que j'ai évoqués tout à l'heure puisque
c'est un surcoût financier et
administratif donc l'amendement qui est
proposé et de que l'entrée en vigueur
qui est prévu dans le texte au 1er
janvier 2015 soit décalé au 1er janvier
2017 pour les entreprises employant
moins de 20 salariés merci avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur
dans son explication notre collègue
n'était pas là-dessus puisque en fait
cet article vous demandez la suppression
de l'article 7
demandez la suppression de l'article 7
bien évidemment nous n'y sommes pas
favorables c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci même avis du
gouvernement même avis je vais donc
mettre aux voix
l'amendement numéro 9 qui vise à
supprimer l'article quels sont ceux qui
sont pour son adoption
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté et je mets au voile
article 7 quels sont ceux qui sont pour
adopter l'article 7
avec contraire il est adopté
article 8 même vote même vote article 9
même vote 9 bis même vote et nous en
arrivons à l'article 10 avec
l'amendement 10 de Monsieur Cardou
ah bon
le groupe communiste vote pour le
pour l'article 10 9 10 pardon
un rendement 10 monsieur Cardot à
l'article 10
il a défendu
tout à l'heure par erreur parfait quelle
est la vie de la Commission
voilà donc c'est un avis défavorable de
la commission
voix qu'elles sont ceux qui sont pour
adopter l'amendement 10
avec contraire il n'est pas adopté je
mets aux voix cette fois l'article 10
qu'elles sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption de l'article 10
avec contraire il est adopté article 10
bis même vote pour
article 11 même vote
abstention il est adopté et nous en
arrivons à l'article 12 avec
l'amendement 12 monsieur Cardou
viens à l'amendement numéro 12 donc cet
amendement vise à
clarifier des dispositions de cette
alinéa permettant de poursuivre une
activité même en liquidant une pension
et donc de continuer à souffrir des
droits pensions pour ses activités en
indiquant clairement que les jurys
d'examens d'État sont visés par ailleurs
sont concernés selon une circulaire
ministérielle de 1984 les personnes qui
donnent des consultations à caractère
discontinue ne les occupons pas plus de
15 heures par semaine en moyenne pendant
l'année il est nécessaire de rehausser
cette limite pour viser plus largement
le cumul d'activités judiciaire avec des
honoraires merci avis de la commission
madame le rapporteur
monsieur le Président c'est un avis
défavorable comme lors de la première
lecture merci même à vie Madame le
Ministre même avis je le mets au voie
quels sont ceux qui sont pour adopter
l'amendement 12
avec le contraire il n'est pas adopté
amendement monsieur Cardot
et par la même occasion le 17 rectifier
donc la demande demande 11 concerne
toujours les retraites des précautions
libérales dont on ne sait qui est pour
la plupart prennent leur retraite à
l'âge de 65 ans et le poids de ces
régimes complémentaires et parfois très
important dans les retraites des
intéressés jusqu'à 85%, il serait donc
injuste de ne pas prendre en compte
cette différence de situation cet
amendement permettra par exemple un
salarié qui a liquidé ses droits à
retraite d'exercer ensuite une activité
libérale jusqu'à l'âge de l'utilisation
sans décote en se constituant des droits
certaines professions notamment
médicales sont caractérisées par un
déséquilibre démographique donc
déséquilibre démographiques ou d'anciens
médecins qui ont pris leur retraite
pourrait continuer une activité à temps
partiel ne serait-ce comme j'avais déjà
souligné au service des collectivités
qui ont un besoin de plus en plus
fréquents de médecins pour leur activité
et donc en fin d'encourager leur
exercice il est donc justifié de
conférer des avantages supplémentaires à
leur exercice le maintien de la
possibilité de s'ouvrir des droits à
pension relève de cette catégorie par
ailleurs certains salariés en fin de
carrière ont pu subir de longues
périodes de chômage sans pouvoir
retrouver un emploi avant liquider leur
pension de retraite il est injuste de ne
pas permettre de telles personnes qui
auraient par exemple la possibilité
d'exercer une activité libérale de ne
pas se constituer de droit ainsi
l'ouverture de nouveaux droits leur
permettra d'obtenir lors d'une seconde
retraite un niveau de revenu plus décent
ainsi par exemple un cadre qui
retrouvera une activité de conseil
indépendant pourrait se constituer des
droits et en particulier on avait déjà
visé en première lecture des activités
d'experts judiciaires
merci avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur
c'est un avis monsieur le Président
c'est un avis défavorable puisque cet
amendement
contredit l'objet même de l'article 12
qui est justement de généraliser le
principe avant de afin de renforcer
l'équité entre les assurés
gouvernement Madame le Ministre même
avis je le mets au vois qu'elles sont
ceux qui sont pour adopter l'amendement
non il est pas il n'est pas adopté
amendement 17 rectifié qu'il défend ce
monsieur Cardot
donc c'est un amendement présenté par
Monsieur Beaumont qui va se solliciter
pour le défendre pour son compte donc
l'article 12 du présent projet doit
générer le principe de cotisation non
génératrice de droit retraite dès lors
qu'un droit est liquidé dans un régime
légalement obligatoire de retraite de
base or les règles d'acquisition des
droits retraite dans la plupart des
régimes complémentaires des professions
libérales rendrait ce système très
pénalisant pour les professionnels
libéraux dans la mesure où contrairement
au régime de base le taux plein ne peut
être acquis comme j'ai souligné tout à
l'heure qu'à 65 ou 67 ans quel que soit
la durée d'assurance et pourquoi il
convient d'exclure les régimes
complémentaires d'assurance vieillesse
et professionnelle libéraux du champ
d'application de ce dispositif merci
avis de la commission
que pour l'amendement précédent c'est un
avis défavorable même avis du
gouvernement merci je le mets aux voix
qu'elles sont ceux qui sont pour adopter
l'article l'amendement 17 rectifié
il n'est pas adopté je mets au voile
article 12 quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 12
avis contraire il est adopté
article 12 bis même vote
article 12 termes votes ils sont adoptés
nous en arrivons à l'article 13 avec
l'amendement 13 monsieur Cardou quelle
belle concordance
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
proposons en effet de supprimer
l'article 13 interprète le 13 dit que
dans les six mois suivant la
promulgation de la présente loi le
Gouvernement remet au Parlement un
rapport sur l'évolution
des droits familiaux afin de mieux
compenser les effets de l'arrivée
d'enfant au foyer sur la carrière et les
pensions des femmes alors je nous allons
bien sûr nous voulons supprimer cet
article et nous voulions souligner aussi
que nous ne sommes pas du tout d'accord
avec la politique du gouvernement
s'agissant de la famille en effet on
voit que la famille est de plus en plus
attaquée par le gouvernement je ne
citerai que quatre mesures la baisse du
plafond du conscient familial de 2000 à
2500 euros la diminution programmée de
la page dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 la
suppression de la réduction d'impôt pour
frais de scolar de scolarité la
fiscalisation des bonus pour trois
enfants qui figurent dans ce projet de
réforme donc un rapport supplémentaire
n'est pas forcément de bonne augure
merci Monsieur Merci quelle est la vie
de la commission madame leur rapporteur
de l'article 13 merci avis du
gouvernement même avis mais ma vie je le
mets au bois qu'elles sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption de la demande 13
il n'est pas adopté et je mets au voie
cette fois l'article 13 quels sont ceux
qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté article 13
bis à même vote même va-t-il être adopté
article 13 bis amendement 32 qu'il
défend madame Cohen
oui l'article 13 bis prévoit que le
gouvernement remette au Parlement un
rapport relatif aux pensions de
réversion de telle sorte que les règles
relatives aux pensions à ces pensions
donc dans le sens d'une meilleure prise
en compte du niveau de vie des conjoints
survivants donc soit pris en compte
cette formulation nous interroge puisque
cela pourrait conduire à une réduction
des montants versés ou un durcissement
des règles pour bénéficier des droits
versés au titre des pensions de
réversion nous serons donc
particulièrement vigilants une vigilance
qui débute ici puisque c'est un moment
propose de compléter la rédaction
actuelle en demandant que celui-ci
compte également une évaluation du coût
et des effets pour les assurer et les
comptes sociaux de la suppression des
conditions d'âge qui sont on le sait
pénalisantes ces conditions
réintroduites par Nicolas Sarkozy dans
la loi du 17 décembre 2008 ont modifié
les règles en vigueur de telle sorte que
désormais l'âge minimum requis pour
bénéficier de la réversion varie en
fonction de la date de décès de l'assuré
si glissait survenu avant le 1er janvier
2009 le conjoint ou l'ex-conjoint peut
prétendent à la réversion à partir de 51
ans pour un décès survenant à partir de
2009 l'âge d'ouverture du droit à la
pension de réversion est fixée à 55 ans
ces modifications portant sur les
mesures d'âge liées à la loi de 2008 ont
suscité vous en souvenez peut-être un
fort mécontentement puisqu'elles ont
fait en réalité elles ont eu pour effet
de réduire le montant des pensions d'une
partie de nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens c'est pourquoi il nous
semble opportun de préciser que l'érable
le rapport étudiera notamment la
suppression des bandages merci quelle
est la ville de la commission madame
leur rapporteur comment en première
lecture c'est un avis de sagesse qui est
donné sur cet amendement merci avis du
gouvernement
même avis je vais donc le mettre au bois
qu'elles sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire il est adopté et je mets
au voile article 13 bis quels sont ceux
qui souhaitent adopter l'article 13 bis
avis contraire il est adopté même vote
sur le 14 même vote nous arrivons à
l'article 15 avec l'amendement 14 de
Monsieur Cardot
le Président Madame le Ministre chers
collègues c'est encore un amendement de
suppression de l'article 15 qui concerne
le dispositif carrière longue puisque
les précédentes réforme de retraite mise
en place par les gouvernements
précédents en 2003 et en 2010 avait
amélioré le dispositif et mis en place
le dispositif de carrière longue mais
après l'alternance en juillet 2012 se
décrit a fait l'objet d'une extension
qui en dénature l'objectif initial qui
était de contrebalancer les mesures
d'âge légal pour les jeunes ayant
commencé à travailler avant 18 ans à
l'occasion de se décret donc ce décret
2012 le gouvernement a compensé par une
hausse de cotisations des actifs et des
employeurs avec une augmentation de la
CSG le retour de la retraite à 60 ans
pour ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 20 ans 107 compensation le décret
du juillet du 2 juillet 2012 aurait
fortement aggravé le déficit du régime
général au cœur de ce projet de loi
c'était contraire à ce qui avait été
voté auparavant donc par esprit de
cohérence alors que les parlementaires
UMP était opposés au décret de juillet
2012 il reste opposé à une continuelle
extension du dispositif carrière longue
qui aura un impact négatif sur
l'équilibre du système des retraites à
l'horizon 2020 merci quelle est la vie
de la commission madame le rapporteur
c'est amendement vise à supprimer
l'élargissement du dispositif carrière
longue c'est donc un avis défavorable de
la commission merci avis du gouvernement
madame la ministre évidemment
défavorable merci je vais donc le mettre
au bois qu'elles sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption de l'amendement 14
avec contraire il n'est pas adopté je
mets aux voiles l'article 15 qu'elles
sont ceux qui souhaitent adopter
l'article 15
avis contraire il est adopté même vote
sur le 16 même vote article 16 bis avec
un amendement 49 de Monsieur deux
Essarts pardon contre le 16 alors
attendez on va reprendre
article 16 quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption de l'article 16
avis contraire
il est adopté
un moment 49 à l'article 16 bis monsieur
2 Essarts
il est retiré je mets au voile article
16 bis
ah pardon il était l'électricité
statique l'avait à collé au 49
alors 33 madame Pasquet
merci monsieur le Président comme vous
le savez seul et stage soumis à
gratification c'est à dire d'une durée
de deux mois au moins d'un lieu pour les
employeurs au versement de cotisations
sous réserve faut-il le préciser que les
stagiaires perçoivent de l'entreprise
d'accueil une rémunération supérieure au
montant de la gratification légale qui
n'excède pas 500 euros il ressort de
cette disposition que les stages les
plus précaires coûte moins cher aux
employeurs et ces derniers sont excités
par la loi sous rémunérer leur
stagiaires puisque s'il leur venait à
l'idée d'être plus généreux que leurs
homologues ils sont qui s'en tiennent à
la gratification légale il serait alors
soumis au versement de cotisations vous
savez nous sommes opposés à ces
mécanismes qui conduisent à favoriser la
précarité plutôt qu'à favoriser des
conditions d'accueil et des stages
dégradés
quel est l'objet de cet amendement qui
propose la progression de l'article elle
242 4-1 du code de la sécurité sociale
merci avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur tu me demandes de retrait
sinon c'est un avis défavorable merci la
vie du gouvernement défavorable
défavorable l'amendement est maintenue
madame parcequet il est maintenu donc je
le mets on voit qu'elles sont ceux qui
sont pour son adoption
il n'est pas adopté et je vais mettre au
voie donc l'article 16 bis quels sont
ceux qui souhaitent adopter l'article 16
bis
avis contraire
abstention il est adopté
article sester qu'elles sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article
il est adopté
article 17 même vote abstention
article 18
même vote
pour
avec contraire
avec
avis contraire
il est adopté nous en arrivons à
l'article 19 avec l'amendement 34 madame
Cohen
avec cet amendement nous portons
l'ambition de prendre des mesures tout à
la fois concrète et urgente permettant
d'accélérer l'égalité réelle de
rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes un sujet d'autant plus important
que ces inégalités de salaire
s'accompagnent d'inégalités de pension
et de retraite d'autant plus
insupportable que les retraites sont
déjà inférieures au salaire nous n'avons
que trop souvent dressé le constat que
des entreprises n'avancent pas sur ces
questions par manque de volonté ainsi
que aussi par conviction il existe des
entreprises récidivistes à l'instar de
certains d'ailleurs partis politiques
qui préfèrent payer des pénalités plutôt
que de mettre en place des accords
favorants favorisant l'égalité notre
message doit être clair et ferme ces
entreprises doivent se conformer à ce
que la loi prévoit appliquer toute la
loi et non pas uniquement des petits
morceaux de loi à cette fin nous
proposons en cas de récidive le
doublement de la pénalité il s'agit bien
de sanctionner des entreprises qui ne
respectent pas la loi et qui persiste et
qui signe en quelque sorte
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur parce que c'est
amendement n'a pas de lien direct avec
le texte et particulièrement avec
l'article 19 c'est une demande de
retrait de la commission sinon un avis
défavorable c'est quelle est la vie du
gouvernement défavorable merci il est
maintenu madame Pasquier il est maintenu
je le mets au vois qu'elles sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption de l'amendement
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté je mets au voie
l'article 19 quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 19
avis contraire il est adopté nous en
arrivons à l'article 20 avec une demande
de prise de parole de Monsieur Emery de
Montesquieu
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cet article supprime
la condition de durée d'assurance dans
le régime des non salariés agricoles
pour bénéficier de la pension majorée de
référence dont peuvent bénéficier ces
ressortissants
il s'agit de garantir que la pension en
question atteigne un montant minimum
une mesure qui s'inscrit dans la lignée
de la fixation à 75% du SMIC de la
pension minimale des exploitants
agricoles d'ici à 2017
nous ne pouvons qui souscrire et bien
que nous pensions qu'il faut être
beaucoup plus ambitieux et garantir un
minimum vieillesse à 75% du SMIC pour
tous
mais cet article est l'occasion pour
nous de vous interroger et vous alerter
madame la ministre sur une singularité
étonnante pour ne pas dire choquante de
la pension de base d'exploitants
agricoles cette dernière est constituée
de deux éléments
une retraite forfaitaire qu'il appelle
pas d'observation particulière de notre
part il retraite proportionnelle qui est
une retraite par point or une étude
attentive de la partie proportionnelle
de la retraite des non salariés
agricoles faites apparaître son
caractère non proportionnel en effet les
points sont attribués annuellement en
fonction du revenu cotisé selon des
modalités déterminées par voie
réglementaire
en vertu du Règlement actuellement en
vigueur 23 points sont attribués pour un
revenu compris entre 0 et 5658 euros par
an entre 23 et 30 points revenus compris
entre 5658 et 7409 euros par an 30
points revenus compris entre 7409 et
15000 de 0,51 euros par an entre 30 et
104 points pour un revenu compris entre
1500051 et
37032 euros par an autrement dit la
tribution et la valeur des points est en
fonction du revenu et ne sont pas
proportionnelles les 23 premiers points
valent 246 euros les 7 suivants 250
euros mais le 30e écoutez Madame le
Ministre le 30e 764
2 euros
la progressivité repart ensuite jusqu'au
de la de 1500051 euros de revenus
annuels le point vaut environ 300 euros
il y a donc un palier une tranche plate
non certes au niveau des revenus les
plus modestes mais tout de même de
revenus encore très faible alors que les
revenus les plus élevés sont eux très
favorisés cela n'est pas admissible rien
ne justifie il faut donc Madame le
Ministre absolument réformer ce barème
et puisqu'il y a injustice il y a
urgence
de Monsieur des Essarts
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame le rapporteur
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues c'est amendement
vise à instaurer la proportionnalité des
cotisations retraite des non salariés
agricoles je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
faille remettre en cause les modalités
actuelles de cotisation des noms
salariés sans en avoir évaluer les
conséquences financières et peut-être
encore plus sans en avoir discuter avec
les représentants du monde agricole
l'article visé par cet amendement porte
sur l'assurance vieillesse
complémentaire
facultative dans la cotisation est déjà
proportionnelle c'est celle là qui est
concernée et ne porte pas sur le régime
d'assurance vieillesse obligatoire
dénonce salariés agricoles c'est donc un
avis défavorable merci quelle est la vie
du gouvernement
même avis monsieur des Essarts
je peux comprendre la deuxième partie
puisque vous avez dire de dire que
l'amendement est pas bon mais pas la
première partie de votre argumentaire
madame la rapporteur
il y a un projet de loi qui parle
justement de la retraite dénon salariés
agricoles c'est bien nous ce dont nous
parlons donc on les a consultés
normalement sur ce point il y a une
première lecture il y a des amendements
qui proposent quelque chose et un mois
plus tard on est dit non non on n'a pas
le temps de les consulter il faut avoir
ça plus tard enfin franchement mais
alors comment on travaille comment on
travaille c'est à dire à quoi sert une
deuxième lecture normalement les gens y
ont réfléchi puisque c'est dans le
projet de loi au départ donc ils sont il
y a au moins on a les interlocuteurs on
a les personnes qui sont qui ont
réfléchi qu'on donnait une position il y
a effectivement des données nouvelles de
la part des parlementaires mais faut pas
renvoyer un projet de loi dans 5 ans ou
de propositions de loi que nous serions
obligés de faire mais enfin on va vite
dans la société d'aujourd'hui ne dites
pas que le que le rythme parlementaire
ne peut pas
avec un mois on a quand même le temps de
passer 4 ou 5
beaucoup de téléphone de faire une
réunion en urgence sur ce point là pour
demander la vie des gens c'est pas
simplement par rapport à mon amendement
je regrette qu'il soit pas pris mais
mais franchement c'est les délais c'est
les délais les délais qui sont demandés
pour arriver à déboucher sur des choses
tout à l'heure il y a eu le décret pour
que les gens puissent travailler
lorsqu'ils sont bénéficiaires de
l'espace ça a l'air de prendre un temps
considérable il y a une situation
d'urgence dans ce pays il y a une
situation d'urgence et si à chaque fois
mais non mais c'est à chaque fois pour
reporter les décisions ça veut dire que
le parlementaire n'est pas trop sérieux
comment vous voulez vous expliquer que
quand justement on dit mais les
parlementaires qu'est-ce que vous faites
lorsqu'il y a un projet de loi on en
discute s'il y a des réponses rapides
ben voilà au moins les gens ils disent
bon ils sont pour en considération ils
ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu lorsqu'on
arrive là et qu'on entend ah il
réfléchir à me monsieur le parlementaire
vous dites une chose intéressante mais
faut qu'on prenne le temps de consulter
tout ça qu'est-ce que vous croyez que ça
fait ça qu'est-ce que ça induit dans la
tête des gens c'est toujours reporté à
demain et que malgré que nous prions le
temps de discuter mais malgré qu'il y
ait du bon sens dans les amendements
c'est discuter à demain
merci Monsieur de Montesquieu
bien entendu je partage les propos de
mon collègue et ami de ses sœurs mais je
voudrais simplement que vous soyez
attentif à deux chiffres
les 23 premiers points valent 246 euros
les 7 suivants
250 euros
mais le 30e
7642 euros
c'est-à-dire que cette chose cet
anomalie nous est pas apparu et vraiment
quelque chose de stupéfiant et qu'on dit
dans les pas au courant
vraiment ça monte de la materisme
merci je vais donc mettre voir cet
amendement 50
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire
il est adopté
je mets au voie l'article 20 quels sont
ceux qui sont pour l'adoption de
l'article 20
pour
avis contraire il est adopté même votre
sur l'article 21
même vote
idem sur le 22
il est adopté article 23 2 amendements
identiques en discussion commune
l'amendement 36 madame Pasquet
sur le Président vous le savez madame la
ministre nous sommes nombreuses et
nombreux sur tous les bancs de notre
assemblée avoir contesté la mesure qui
figure dans cet article à savoir la
suppression du critère de la
reconnaissance de la qualité de
travailleurs handicapés dans les
conditions permettant aux travailleurs
en situation de handicap de liquider la
retraite à taux plein des 55 ans
le fait de remplacer le taux
d'incapacité permanente à 80% par celui
de 50% est une très bonne mesure mais
une bonne mesure immédiatement
contrebalancée par le fait que vous ayez
pris la décision de supprimer cette
faculté pour celles et ceux qui sont
bénéficiaires de l'arrière QTH sans
pouvoir faire la démonstration d'un taux
d'incapacité de 50%. cela inquiète les
personnes concernées et afin de répondre
à ces inquiétudes la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale
adopter sur l'initiative de son
rapporteur un amendement prévoyant que
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2015 les titulaires
de la RQTH pourront encore prétendre à
bénéficier de ce droit si cette mesure
atténue une disposition injuste elle ne
constitue pas la réponse qu'attend des
personnes en situation de handicap les
titulaires d'une RQTH
qui ne sont pas atteints d'une
incapacité permanente de 50% et dans les
droits à la retraite ne seront ouverts
qu'après 2015 ne pourront pas bénéficier
d'un départ anticipé à la retraite comme
nous l'affirmions en première lecture
les critères de la RQTH et de
l'incapacité permanente même si le taux
de cette dernière a été ramené à 50% ne
sont pas nécessairement les mêmes on
peut être lourdement handicapé reconnu
comme tel par exemple par la Maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
sans pour autant remplir les critères
permettant de bénéficier d'un taux
d'incapacité permanent de 50%. par
conséquent si cette mesure demeure en
l'état elle apparaîtra et inévitablement
comme une injustice ce qu'elle est déjà
c'est pourquoi nous proposons de
rétablir dans la durée que le bénéfice
de cet article au titulaire d'une RQTH
merci amendement 54 monsieur Tropéano
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre cet amendement qui vient d'être
défendu par notre collègue du groupe
CRSC avait été adopté en premier lecture
il s'agit de maintenir le critère de la
reconnaissance de qualité de
travailleurs handicapé pour l'accès des
travailleurs handicapés au dispositif de
retraite anticipée certes vous avez
accepté que les deux critères coexistent
pendant une phase transitoire de deux
algues cela n'est pas suffisant par
ailleurs madame la ministre délégué
chargé des personnes âgées nous avaient
expliqué que réintroduire la RQTH
reviendra à maintenir un critère à la
fois inopérant et complexe cet argument
est discutable supprimer le droit à la
retraite anticipée pour les titulaires
de la RQTH Marc bien au contraire un
véritable recul les travailleurs
handicapés qui ne pourront pas justifier
d'un taux d'incapacité de 50% sur une
durée suffisante seront gravement
pénalisés
je rappellerai enfin que le dispositif
de RQTH s'adresse aux personnes en
capacité de travailler mais qui présente
des difficultés à exercer certaines
types d'activités professionnelles en
raison des problèmes de santé qu'il
s'agisse de maladies ou d'un handicap il
en résulte que le titulaire le titulaire
de la RQTH est exposé à une usure
prématurée de son organisme ce qui
justifie qu'il puisse tout à fait
bénéficier d'une retraite anticiper
quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre Michel
collègue vous l'avez dit le projet de
loi initial prévoyait effectivement de
supprimer
ce critère de qualité de travailleur
handicapés et donc la RK
excusez-moi
pour ne garder que celui de la
reconnaissance d'un taux d'incapacité
permanente à baisser de 80% à 50%, vous
l'avez dit mais à l'issue de la première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
secrétaire de la RQTH a été conservé
pendant une période transitoire afin de
ne pas léser les assurer qui sont
proches de la retraite anticiper des
travailleurs handicapés par un
changement
rapide des règles c'est donc l'objet du
paragraphe deux bis de l'article 23 donc
pour cette période transitoire la
préoccupation des auteurs de ces
amendements de ces deux amendements le
36 et le suivant on peut considérer
qu'il a été entendu je précise
d'ailleurs que rien n'empêche le comité
de suivi des retraites de se pencher sur
cette question pour voir comment les
deux dispositions
s'il est nécessaire de les qu'elle
continue à à être retenu toutes les deux
ou pas je propose donc en retrait de cet
amendement de ces amendements sinon la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
merci quelle est la ville du
gouvernement mais ma vie pour les mêmes
raisons excellente exprimées merci
l'amendement est maintenu il est
maintenu donc je vais le
je vous en prie
madame le ministre mes chers collègues
comme nous l'avions dit en premier
lecture la reconnaissance de la qualité
de travailleur handicapés peut-être
attribuée à toute personne dont les
capacités physiques ou mentales sont
diminués par un handicap mais aussi
celles souffrant d'une maladie chronique
ou d'un problème de santé ayant des
répercussions au travail la RQTH
s'adresse à ceux qui subissent des
difficultés dans leur travail ou face à
l'accès à l'emploi en raison de leur
état de santé supprimer la RQTH au motif
qu'elle n'aurait pas été suffisamment
demandée par les travailleurs handicapés
nous paraît faire peu de cas de la
réalité ce système est complexe et
suppose une mise en œuvre progressive
nous souhaitons donc que soit adopter
les amendements numéro 36 et 54 afin que
la rqthk a commencé à être mise en œuvre
sur le terrain fasse ses preuves c'est
pourquoi le groupe UMP votera ces deux
amendements
merci je vais donc mettre vos voix ces
deux amendements identiques qu'elles
sont ceux qui sont pour leur adoption
avis contraire
ils sont adoptés
amendement 35 madame Cohen oui les
personnes en situation de handicap qui
poursuivent leur activité au-delà de
l'âge légal prévu au premier alinéa de
l'article
l350-1 du code de la sécurité sociale
bénéficie d'une majoration en fonction
de la durée ayant donné lieu à
cotisation pour ces assurés la
majoration de pensions constituent un
élément non négligeable or ce que l'on
entend et du terrain atteste des assurés
éligibles n'ont pas eu accès à la
majoration notamment parce que le régime
d'affiliation ne les en a pas informés
et donc ça n'a pas été appliqué
automatiquement si plus zen n'est pas
rare qu'en raison d'un parcours
professionnel chaotique des personnes en
situation de handicap qui ne
rempliraient pas la condition d'âge
permettant le départ de retraite à taux
plein et n'ayant pas cotisé suffisamment
de trimestre continue de travailler
après l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite cette situation conduit
paradoxalement à ce la retraite des
personnes en situation de handicap qui
auraient travaillé au-delà de l'âge
légal mais avant l'âge légal permettant
le bénéfice d'une retraite sans décote
se retrouve au final avec une pension de
vieillesse moins importante que s'ils
avaient pris leur retraite par
anticipation avant l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite en 2006 Philippe basse
consciente cette situation adressée au
directeur de la CNAV de la MSA et du RSI
une lettre ministérielle afin qu'il
veille à ce que soit effectivement
appliqué la majoration aux assurés
n'ayant pas bénéficié du droit à la
retraite anticipée pour les personnes
handicapées mais qui en rempliraient les
conditions avant l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite malheureusement là encore
forcée de constater que cette majoration
qui semble ne pas être intégrée
automatiquement n'est pas
systématiquement applicable ce qui
évidemment est un préjudice aux
personnes qui sont en situation de
handicap aussi afin que cette majoration
est enfin un caractère automatique il
convient de prévoir dans la loi que le
décret d'application concernant ce
dispositif intègre obligatoirement un
volet information en direction des
assurés de telle sorte que chacune et
chacun d'entre eux soient informés de
leurs droits et puisse enfin prétendre à
cette majoration telle est le sens de
cet amendement qui avait reçu un vote
favorable en première lecture par notre
Haute Assemblée merci quelle est la
ville de la Commission
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues vous considérez
que les assurés handicapés sont
insuffisamment informés du droit
majoration c'est pourquoi vous proposer
que le décret définissant le montant de
la majoration précise les modalités
d'information des assurés concernés en
première lecture notre commission avait
proposé un avis de sagesse mais madame
la ministre au nom du gouvernement avait
indiqué en séance publique que pour ceux
qui partent en retraite anticipée la
majoration de retraite est appliquée
systématiquement sans qu'il soit besoin
pour les assurer d'en faire la demande
quant à ceux qui ne partent pas en
retraite anticipée une instruction
avez-vous dit madame la ministre va
rappeler aux caisses de retraite que ces
assurés doivent bénéficier de cette
majoration l'amendement est donc
satisfait c'est donc une demande de
retrait que nous vous faisons
merci avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre oui demande de retrait ou à vie
défavorable en tout cas la condition est
déjà satisfaite
amendement 37 madame Pasquet
l'assurance vieillesse des parents
foyers garantissent sous certaines
conditions une continuité dans les
droits à la retraite d'une personne qui
aurait cessé ou réduit son activité
professionnelle pour s'occuper d'un
enfant ou d'un adulte handicapé au foyer
familial alors différentes associations
acteurs dans le champion du handicap ont
souligné le fait que les personnes
assurant la charge de leur conjoint
handicapée ne bénéficient pas de
l'affiliation à l'assurance vieillesse
des personnes assumant la charge au
foyer familial d'un handicapé adulte la
VPF pour les périodes allant de 1999 à
2004 en effet la circulaire DSS 4C
numéro 239 du 15 avril 1998 relative aux
conditions d'application à l'assurance
vieillesse des personnes assumant la
charge au foyer familial d'un handicapé
adulte précisé que l'article L 381 1
du code de la sécurité sociale ne visez
que les parents d'enfants handicapés et
par extension les parents d'enfants
handicapés devenus adultes mais pas les
conjoints s'occupant de leur époux ou
épousent handicapés l'article 34 de la
Loi 2003 775 du 21 août 2003 portant
réforme des retraites à élargi
expressément le bénéfice à la VPF aux
personnes assurant la charge de leur
conjoint handicapés et ce à compter du
1er janvier 2004 il en découle que pour
la période allant du 1er janvier 1999 au
1er janvier 2004 les cotisations non
financées par les CAF font défaut au
compte des intéressés étudier les moyens
d'apporter une réponse concrète à ces
personnes nous paraît être une mesure
urgente et le Sénat nous a rejoint
première lecture puisque c'était
maintenant a été adopté c'est pourquoi
nous le représentons aujourd'hui devant
vous
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues en première lecture la
Commission avait demandé sur cet
amendement la vie du gouvernement madame
la ministre nous avait indiqué alors que
la validation des trimestres au titre de
la VPF concerne uniquement les dents
familiales désignés par la personne
handicapée auprès de la Maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
avec confirmation de la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales c'est
affiliation doit être établie
administrativement au moment de la
reconnaissance du handicap elle ne peut
pas concerner des périodes passées y
compris pour le conjoint une affiliation
rétroactive pour une période donnée ne
peut donc pas être envisagée en
conséquence la remise d'un rapport sur
le sujet n'a pas lieu d'être et c'est
donc un avis défavorable merci avis du
gouvernement défavorable merci je le
mets je vois qu'elles sont ceux qui sont
pour adopter l'article l'amende ment 37
pardon
avec contraire
il n'est pas adopté et je mets au voile
article 23 quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 23
avis contraire il est adopté sur
l'article 24 je n'ai pas d'amendement
pas de demande de parole je vais donc
mettre ouvrir l'article 24 qui est pour
l'adoption de l'article 24
avis contraire il est adopté il n'y a
aucun amendement ni demande de parole du
25 au 29 bis puis-je considérer que le
vote elle-même sur ses articles
alors avis divergent sur le 29 sinon
même vote sur les autres
merci
29 bis si vous êtes pour et on arrive à
l'article 30 avec l'amendement 15 de
Monsieur Cardou c'est Madame Debré qu'il
défend
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues l'article
30 a pour objet l'organisation d'un
débat annuel sur les orientations de la
politique des retraites dans la fonction
publique
débat avec les trois fonctions publiques
et les organisations syndicales de
fonctionnaires alors ce projet de loi
fait l'impasse sur 7 milliards d'euros
nécessaires à l'horizon 2020 pour
financer notre système des retraites
notamment pour les retraites des
fonctionnaires par ailleurs au lieu de
prendre les mesures de convergence le
gouvernement prend des mesures qui
entretiennent la rupture entre les
Français en prévoyant d'ores et déjà un
étalement dans le temps des hausses de
cotisation cet amendement de suppression
dénonce une mesure d'affichage et le
manque de responsabilité du gouvernement
sur la retraite des agents de l'État
merci quelle est l'avis de la commission
ou la vie de la commission il est bien
évidemment défavorable puisque par cet
amendement Vous vous opposez au débat
annuel sur les retraites dans la
fonction publique
merci avis du gouvernement défavorable
défavorable je mets donc au bois leur
manquement numéro 15 quels sont ceux
explication de votre madame Pasquier
pardon
merci monsieur le Président sur cette
amendement nous nous obsciendrons en
première lecture nous avions déposé un
amendement
précisant l'organisation d'une élection
au sein des branches de la sécurité
sociale y compris en ce qui concerne les
fonctionnaires ce qui nous paraît être
plus en mesure de favoriser la
démocratie que une simple
consultation des organisations
syndicales c'est la raison pour laquelle
notre groupe s'absiendra sur cet article
merci
je le mets aux voix qu'elles sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption de l'amendement
avec contraire
il n'est pas adopté je mets aux voiles
article 30 quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 30
avis contraire il est adopté l'article
31 avec un amendement 38 madame Cohen
madame Pasquet
même parce que
merci monsieur le Président l'article 31
a pour objet de réformer le pilotage du
régime complémentaire obligatoire ou RCO
dénon salariés agricole Agnès aussi en
la Caisse centrale de la mutualité
sociale agricole la CCMSA si cet article
doit être maintenu et notre amendement
repoussé le conseil d'administration de
la CCMSA aurait pour mission d'équilibre
financier du régime complémentaire
obligatoire afin d'y parvenir il y
appartiendra d'adresser tous les trois
ans au ministre compétent un rapport
détaillant la situation financière du
régime ces perspectives d'équilibre de
long terme ainsi que les risques
auxquels il est exposé mission lui sera
également confiée de proposer s'il
estime que la pérennité du régime est en
cause l'évolution des paramètres à
retenir afin que le régime reste à
l'équilibre ce qui nous fait craindre
comme à l'article 3 que la seule
solution retenue pour favoriser le
retour en équilibre ne consiste qu'à
agir sur la valeur de service du point
de retraite ou en cas ou encore sa
valeur d'achat c'est-à-dire au final sur
le montant des prestations series nous
l'avons dit d'autres voix que celle-ci
existe voilà pourquoi nous souhaitons la
suppression de cet article 31
merci quelle est la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur
la vie de la commission monsieur le
Président et mes chers collègues est
défavorable
puisque cet article 31 que vous
souhaitez supprimer renforce le rôle de
la MSA dans le pilotage du régime
complémentaire obligatoire des non
salariés agricoles vous craignez
l'ouverture d'une voie vers une réforme
systémique je pense que rien ne justifie
cette inquiétude c'est pour cela que
nous émettons un avis défavorable merci
avis du gouvernement ma vie je le mets
aux voix qu'elles sont ceux qui sont
pour adopter l'amendement 38
avec le contraire il n'est pas adopté
amendement 51 monsieur deux Essarts
l'article 31 de ce projet de loi visa
élargir les missions de la Caisse
centrale de la mutualité sociale
agricole d'une simple gestion
administrative vers un réel pilotage il
a ainsi proposé que la Caisse centrale
de l'AMSA puisse recommander tous les
trois ans des évolutions des paramètres
du régime au ministre de tutelle toute
cotisation valeur d'achat et valeur de
service cette évolution vise à aligner
les prérogatives de la MSA sur les
autres régimes complémentaires
professionnels comme le RSI ou
l'Ircantec qui disposent de véritables
pouvoirs de pilotage si cette évolution
peut être saluée il convient aussi de
nous interroger sur la concertation en
effet le pilotage proposé dans cet
article ne serait sans envisager sans
être participation accrue des syndicats
agricoles donc cet amendement vise ainsi
à établir la concertation en amont entre
les syndicats agricoles représentatifs à
l'évocation nationale et la MSA sur les
évolutions du régime de retraite
complémentaire obligatoire leur avis
devrait être consulté avant la remise du
rapport de la MSA au ministre de
l'Agriculture des affaires sociales et
du budget merci quelle est la vie de la
commission madame la rapporteur
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
mon cher collègue la demande que vous
exprimez me semble satisfaite par la
composition même du conseil
d'administration
de la MSA puisque ce conseil
d'administration est divisé en trois
collèges
représentant les exploitants les
salariés et les employeurs agricoles les
principales sensibilités sont
représentés par les organisations
syndicales elles y feront donc valoir
leur position donc c'est un avis
défavorable de la commission
merci quelle est la ville du
gouvernement même avis il est retiré
amendement 52 monsieur des Essarts
prenez votre temps prenez votre temps
cet amendement permettrait aux 74% des
candidats des cotisants agricoles ayant
un revenu inférieur au SMIC annuel et
devant acquitter une cotisation minimum
calculée sur le SMIC d'avoir un appel à
cotisation plus juste la majorité des
paysans sont encore en situation de
surcotisation il convient donc de
remédier à cette situation nous
proposons donc de supprimer l'assiette
minimum d'un niveau de cotisation pour
éviter une surcotisation bien sûr pour
ceux qui déclarent plus qu'il ne
perçoivent il s'agit là de retrouver un
équilibre en réajustant les taux il
s'agit de prendre clairement en compte
le revenu réel et de mettre en place des
taux par palier de revenus des taux
différenciés selon les niveaux de
revenus il s'agit également de plafonner
l'attribution de points jusqu'à un
certain revenu aujourd'hui en effet les
hauts ont venus sont très clairement
favorisés bien qu'il soit soumis au même
taux de cotisation et se voit attribuer
des points sans aucun plafonnement
bonsoir merci quelle est la vie de la
commission madame de montes monsieur le
Président Madame aminis mon cher
collègue nous avons déjà débattu en
première lecture de cette question nous
n'avions pas été à l'époque convaincu
par cette mesure nous ne sommes pas plus
aujourd'hui c'est donc un avis
défavorable de la commission merci même
avec du gouvernement même avis je le
mets au bois quels sont ceux qui
poussent pour adopter l'amendement 52 de
Monsieur deux Essarts
la vie contraire il n'est pas adopté et
je vais mettre au voile l'article 31
quels sont ceux qui veulent l'adopter
l'article 31
avis contraire
il est adopté article 32 avec un
amendement 16 monsieur Cardot
oui parce que le Président Madame le
Ministre chers collègues nous revenons à
nouveau sur l'article 32 qui concerne la
caisse des professions libérales sur
laquelle j'étais intervenu dans la
discussion générale qui je le rappelle
présente un excédent de 15 milliards
d'euros et en fait le gouvernement
s'attaque à cette caisse alors bien sûr
Madame le Ministre en première lecture
vous nous avez dit il n'est pas question
que la volonté du gouvernement soit de
faire main basse sur ces 15 milliards
d'euros et puis dans la foulée du débat
un des parlementaires socialistes a dit
exactement le contraire en nous disant
que c'était trop tentant de récupérer
ses fonds nous l'avons tous entendu donc
moi je pense que il y a aucune raison de
mettre en cause
ces caisses qui ont montré depuis des
années qu'elle savait gérer les
cotisations de leur ressortissants
puisque 15 milliards d'euros si les
régimes généraux arrivaient à sortir de
tels je ne pense pas que le gouvernement
voudrait mettre ma base dessus et
surtout parce que cela montre que quand
on a un âge de départ à la retraite à 65
ans voire plus et bien ça dégage des
excédents c'est ce que nous essayons de
vous faire comprendre depuis le début de
ce débat alors je sais bien on a demandé
à la Cour des comptes et à l'IGAS de
faire des rapports sur le fonctionnement
de ces caisses mais je trouve quand même
que d'abord c'est l'État qui demande à
l'état pas pour la Cour des comptes mais
pour les gars de d'analyser la façon
dont les caisses sont gérées mais quand
on va jusqu'à critiquer dans le rapport
moi j'estime que sont des débats de
valeur de critiquer des placements qu'on
fait ces caisses en particulier s'ils
ont fait des placements vignobles ou en
forêt qui sont des placements tout à
fait honorables et qui peuvent à moyen
ou long terme avoir des rentabilités
suffisantes j'estime que l'État n'est
pas dans son rôle laissons les
professions libérales gérées leur caisse
de retraite comme elle l'entende et
j'espère simplement qu'elle continueront
dans longtemps de dégager de telles
excédents voilà pourquoi nous proposons
un amendement de suppression merci avis
de la commission
défavorable monsieur le Président même
avis du gouvernement même à vie je vais
donc mettre aux voix l'amendement 16 de
Monsieur Cardou quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter
il n'est pas adopté amendement 18
rectifié toujours monsieur Cardot
donc
le sénateur Beaumont qui m'a chargé des
défenses donc ils sont tout à fait je
vais les défendre si vous le permettez
monsieur le Président à la suite pour
éviter d'alourdir le débat le premier et
l'amendement numéro 18 rectifié propose
que la scène VPL soit compétente pour
assurer les équilibres de gestion en
matière de système d'information et le
deuxième le numéro 19 rectifié a pour
objet de
que si cette réforme jusqu'au bout qu'au
moins le directeur de la scène VPN ne
soit pas directement nommé par l'État
auprès de personnes que l'État aura
lui-même choisi mais au moins que il
soit choisi pour
auprès de deux personnes qui auraient
été proposées par le conseil
d'administration de la caisse qui me
semble la moindre des choses en matière
de démocratie de permettre à des
cotisants de se gérer eux-mêmes
merci avis de la commission madame de
montes le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues on a déjà eu ce
débat
pour les mêmes raisons nous émettons un
avis défavorable sur ces deux
amendements merci avis du gouvernement
merci je mets donc voilà l'amendement 18
rectifié de Monsieur Cardou quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté
amendement 19 rectifié monsieur Cardou
il est présenté
même vote même vote je mets au voile
article 32 quels sont ceux qui
souhaitent adopter l'article 32
avec contraires il est adopté même vote
sur le 32 bis
sur le 33
sur le 33 bis
sur le 34
et je vais donc mettre au bois
l'ensemble du projet de loi est-ce qu'il
y a des explications de vote
monsieur des Essarts
très rapidement monsieur le Président
puisque non seulement
comme dirait madame la rapporteur ce
projet de loi nous a été déjà présenté
nous a pas convaincu ça serait
exactement les mots qu'elle a répondu à
mon amendement donc lui retourner
la formule pour ce projet de loi donc ce
n'est pas une posture chers collègues
pour les écologistes augmenter les les
la durée des cotisations n'est pas c'est
un fondamental et pour nous c'est
quelque chose que nous ne pouvons pas
voter d'ailleurs nous l'avions défendu
en 2009 cette position donc je voudrais
pas rappeler on peut toujours évoluer on
peut dire que la situation du pays
l'exige mais on peut quand même dire
que il y a d'autres moyens de résoudre
le problème de du paiement des retraites
je ne vois pas en quoi faire travailler
plus longtemps les seniors donnera du
travail au plus jeune et va permettre
d'alimenter les caisses et c'est quand
même le problème du chômage et de la
répartition de l'emploi qui est posé et
il y a d'autres moyens d'assurer cette
redistribution et la formule n'est pas
chercher dans le travail est toujours
plus ce qui n'est pas possible au niveau
écologique et qui n'est pas souhaitable
au niveau social donc pour nous il y a
un désaccord de fond sur l'article 4 le
fait de reporter et d'assurer le
financement en touchant de façon
indistincte l'ensemble des retraités
aussi bien les faibles retraites que les
plus les retraites plus importantes nous
posent problème donc et nous sommes
opposés à ce texte et nous voterons
contre
merci Madame Debré
le projet de loi sur lequel nous
débattons porte un titre ambitieux il
est en effet censé garantir la pérennité
et la justice du système des retraites
si le titre est prometteur la réalité
est tout autre comment pouvez-vous
affirmer que vous garantirez l'avenir et
la justice du système des retraites avec
cette réforme à minima vous prévoyez une
hausse de la durée d'assurance pour
l'ensemble des régimes de retraite
légalement obligatoire mais vous refusez
de remettre à plat les régimes spéciaux
de retraite certes vous reportez de six
mois la date de revalorisation annuelle
des pensions mais n'a à nos yeux ça
n'est qu'une mesure est
vous faites grand cas du nouveau mode de
pilotage annuel du système de retraite
mais l'avis du comité de suivi des
retraites n'aura aucune valeur
contraignante et mettez-vous réellement
en oeuvre les ajustements qu'il ne
manquera pas de formuler
vous nous dites vous soucier de la
gouvernance des caisses de retraite des
professions libérales et vous décidez
que le directeur de la
CNAVPL sera désormais nommé par décret
mais où est la réflexion concernant la
simplification de la gestion des
multiples régimes de retraite et leur
rapprochement vous nous dites aussi
vouloir vous attaquer à la compétitivité
des entreprises et à la simplification
des formalités administratives allant
même jusqu'à évoquer un choc de
simplification mais vous créez un compte
de prévention de la pénibilité dans la
mise en oeuvre sera une charge
financière très lourde pour les
entreprises quel sera le coût réel de
cette mesure quelles activités quel
métier quel salarié seront concernés
vous nous dites enfin entendre les
doléances de nos concitoyens qui
contestent votre politique fiscale et
pourtant vous pressez vous procédez à un
nouveau matraquage fiscal en règle en
mettant à contribution les entreprises
les salariés les retraités
dans le même temps vous refusez tous les
débats que nous vous avons proposé sur
une réforme systémique du système de
retraite sur l'épargne retraite
individuelle et collective sur
l'allongement de l'âge légal du départ à
la retraite sur le poids de la fiscalité
qui grève de façon drastique le pouvoir
d'achat des Français ou encore sur le
financement des régimes de retraite de
la fonction publique il est temps de
mettre en œuvre des vrais réformes
structurantes en cessant de considérer
la hausse des impôts des taxes et des
cotisations comme le seul remède
possible au mot de notre pays alors que
d'autres solutions existent comme la
réduction des dépenses publiques ce
projet de loi démontre comme d'autres
adoptés depuis le début du quinquennat
que vous faites fausse route tout en
refusant d'affronter la réalité d'une
situation qui n'a fait que s'aggraver
depuis votre arrivée au pouvoir le
groupe UMP ne souscrit pas à ce texte et
en conséquence votre acompte et répondre
tout à l'heure à notre collègue pendant
la DG notre collègue
Vergos versus Argos pardon cargos Vergos
c'est bien ça vous nous avez dit je vous
cite que les socialistes soutiennent ce
projet et doivent le faire fortement il
uttait mieux chers collègues que vous ne
soyez pas que deux voire trois dans
cette hémicycle pendant toute
l'après-midi c'est vrai que vous avez un
tout petit renfort là que l'opposition
soit relativement absente ça peut se
comprendre mais qu'une majorité soit
totalement absente ça se comprend moins
merci Madame Cohen
oui monsieur le Président mais mes chers
collègues c'est vrai que le projet de
loi tel qui suit des débats fait l'objet
de modifications qui sont venus un peu
de tous les bancs certaines d'ailleurs
auxquelles nous sommes associés
volontiers comme certains amendements
qui ont été déposés par le groupe Europe
Écologie Les Verts et d'autres
évidemment dont nous sommes nous nous
dissocions totalement parce que nous ne
les partageons pas et disons cela je
vise particulièrement l'adoption de
l'amendement numéro 1 de nos collègues
vendre et de Madame Dini qui prévoit ni
plus ni moins que de basculer dans les
années à venir vers un régime de
retraite par point et par ailleurs ce
que nous déplorons fortement c'est le
maintien du comité de suivi des
retraites qui prévoit lui aussi en fait
un changement de régime puisque ce
comité est autorisé à envisager la
baisse du taux de redressement des du
rendement des pensions c'est-à-dire en
fait pour parler plus simplement
la diminution des pensions mais qu'il
n'a pas du tout le droit d'envisager une
hausse des cotisations patronales ni
même la taxation de revenus jusqu’à leur
nom soumis à cotisations sociales comme
les revenus financiers des entreprises
alors évidemment nous n'arrêtons pas au
niveau du groupe CRC de faire finalement
des propositions qui paraissent
répétitives dont Dante pour certains qui
peuvent paraître dogmatiques mais le
problème dans la pédagogie il faut
beaucoup répéter nous avons le sentiment
de ne pas être entendu et que toutes les
propositions alternatives de nouveaux
financements de financement différents
sont systématiquement écartés donc
évidemment nous y revenons à chaque fois
parce que nous pensons nous
contrairement effectivement au groupe
UMP qui a quand même la mémoire très
courte parce que qui a orienté des
réformes catastrophiques qui ont mis des
millions de gens dans la rue pour
s'opposer d'ailleurs à ces réformes qui
étaient très négatives mais
contrairement donc au groupe de droites
au groupe de l'UMP
nous pensons pas qu'il y a trop nous
quittons à l'hémicycle du Sénat mais
nous reviendrons nous reviendrons bien
entendu plus largement sur la réforme
des retraites qui est en passe d’être
rejetée par le Sénat dans 24 heures
Sénat le journal c'est tout de suite